[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
okay
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
my
[Music]
me
[Music]
what's going on you guys gaming addict
here uh lord addict i'm assuming some of
you on uh
on on on the podcast know me lord i got
my co-host with me hustle and motivate
what's going on hustle
i'm good um wait wait since you're lord
addict and um it seems like i'm down
with y'all now does that make me lord
hustle now don't need to change my name
or like okay i just need to know you can
it don't matter to me man
like what's funny is people keep like
making fun of like my different uh
personas like because i have gaming at
it lord at it
and i'm like look man first off i can't
help that
see like lord addict is just the gaming
addict
part of it like it's not like
people want me to change my name the
lord addict and it's just like
that that's not the that's the reason
i'm called
lord addict is because of the addict
from gaming addict like i don't have to
get rid of gaming addict i'm called lord
i'd like we ain't calling like cognito
by his full name you know what i'm
saying
yeah yes sir i mean
well no i just want to say i think it
just makes more sense to you know have
everything coincide with one thing i'm
hustling motivate everywhere but you
know for the sex of the show man i do
want to be cohesive so
if you you like you call me hustle for
sure call me lord hustle it's all good
man by the way that's fine so what have
you been playing man what's been going
on with you this week
oh man so i was supposed to start
playing kenneth and i actually tried to
start this live streaming last week but
i wasn't playing that i got caught up
y'all
got caught up in 64 gang i've been
playing no mercy i don't know if you can
see it i've been playing no mercy i just
been trying to
come gearing up for those live streams
so i want to make a creative character
but i need money to buy the moves and
stuff so i kind of want to make that a
whole thing but i've been playing like
no mercy like this entire time and yeah
i mean just just having a good time with
that um how about yourself eddie what
you been running i i think you're
wearing death loop i know you beat that
what else you might lie um
i've been playing a little bit more
bravery default too i'm actually gonna
get
back into the pokemon scene see if i can
get me a competitive team they do have
that uh that horrible looking remake
coming out at the end of the month
next month look i'm not saying that's
like
not bad or anything like that like but
i'm saying like in terms of pokemon i
don't want it to look like animal
crossing if that makes sense to you but
is that going to stop me from buying it
probably not and probably still going to
buy it but you know
it's it it is it is going to be
interesting man it's going to be
interesting how that goes you know we do
got a great show for you guys man we're
going to be talking about
you know i know it's not on here but we
are going to talk about the
the last of us two factions being
delayed again well it's not really been
delayed but you get get what i'm saying
man you get what i'm saying and then
we're going to talk i kind of want to
break down the xbox studios man like i i
really do i want to break down exactly
what
we think is going to happen with these
studios kind of quality games they're
going to make i i want to talk about
something like that as well and then
then we're probably going to end it with
that halo beta man did you play any of
that this weekend hustle or or did you
get a chance to because i know
only being two days sometimes it's hard
to get into stuff that's like only got a
time limit
man they had me feeling like uh i
believe his name is eric andre i was
like let me in they would not let me in
the joint and i signed up for it when um
when when they had the e3 showcase with
all the 28 games going to game pass and
all that i signed up for it then and
they still wouldn't let me yeah now from
what i understand they'll have a free
they'll have like a weekend this weekend
i'm coming to where everybody can like
play we just got to like re-sign up but
i had given them my i had given 343 my
information i signed up for the beta i
did like the whole dx
dax thing whatever that information is
the way you show them how you what's
what your pc is would you give them all
the information i get i took a
screenshot gave them all that
information i know a few of my homies
got in but i couldn't get in and i was
like come on man but um
i guess we'll we'll talk about that or i
guess maybe we can get into it i mean
from what i saw i saw alex oh no as alex
he streamed it
it was looking shaky but i think it was
looking shaky because he tried to stream
it as well
um yeah i saw eric yeah what's up it
seemed like um erica's
uh she was enjoying it a lot it seemed
like alex having more like
uh technical issues than anything
yeah um eric empire who's another like
big halo guy
i saw him stream it his stream was
perfectly fine he had um his much
wreaker weaker gpu than i have and like
his stream was perfectly fine so i'm not
really sure what what that issue was hey
uh let me ask you something did you see
that uh that melee glitch oh you talking
about where they madeline like they
one-piece man like
[Laughter]
like look at
what's funny he's like oh my god i heard
kids move say that they should keep it
in there i'm like okay kid oh come on
see
some crazy stuff like that man that way
he has a way to cheap kill me so he can
claim he killed me one time in a hundred
games
shout out to smoove man but no no no
that that the uh
you know that tech test it looked fun
man i'm just i'm just upset that i
couldn't take part in it um it's just
this is one of them things hopefully
i'll be able to get into the next one um
i do want to ask anybody and everybody
in the chat
well first of all how are our audio
levels first of all second of all was
anybody able to get into the tech test
if so let me know your experience in the
chat
i think our audios are pretty decent
because normally
that this chat's pretty vocal when our
audios are pretty out of this way so you
got the ten dollar superchat from drawn
tj
i i
i think you want me to call you drawing
tj or drawn in tj we'll go with that man
because i feel like that's the better
one man attica too i'll handle that here
in a second so hi guys by the way uh you
had to go in the insider app on xbox to
get it love you guys this is by far the
best table ever uh yeah i would have to
honestly agree let me change this real
quick all right uh attic while you're
doing that um i did do that um tj i did
that like i literally signed up and did
my thing and i was like i literally had
everything in order like this because
they asked you all that answer for your
email they asked you for all that
information so i'm like cool we in there
well everybody else what's up i think
what it is is
i think that
did they they could have been a little
bit more clear on how things were going
with this kind of uh perform uh the the
the app in general because when
you better be grateful because last time
hustle the the last one they did for
like that weekend it was bad like i i
remember
playing uh playing something else and
just sitting on my xbox something at the
dashboard hoping that would let it go
through one time
and
look like
i respect the way 343 is handling this
because to me they want to make sure
that this comes out when it works
properly
and i always have to give people props
for that because what's going to happen
is
now that first they did the pv uh pvp
against bots and it was only boxing
people was like oh
why is it just bots you know that makes
no sense
hustle the reason they did boss is
because if you're only if you're feeling
half the team of boss does it make more
sense that you're going to cover how
like double the servers
because
half the teams bought so you need two
lobbies to do one actual official game
so you're doubling the the traffic in
the actual server to test the servers
that's the reason they did the boss
oh well okay so thank you for explaining
that to me because i kind of was a
little in the dark on that too i'm sure
they had good reason but i mean yeah i
mean nobody should really complain like
these are tech tests like anything that
we throw at it like with the melee
glitch and all that we supposed to throw
all of that and plus you know plus more
um at the team um really quick dark
queen gaming happy birthday
i hope all is well um you don't have to
share your aj anything but i hope you
got everything that you wanted for your
birthday this year yeah definitely happy
birthday man we got a five dollar super
chat from drawing nti your audio is good
i got in it's awesome sorry to hear that
bro you'll definitely get into it this
weekend stay cool guys
is this weekend public
yeah so this weekend from what i
understood is public to everybody um
it's one of the one of my homies
centered in the dm said it was public to
everybody but you have to be even i
think even the xbox players but you have
to go through the app so i guess the app
is made available on the dashboard i'm
assuming i'm gonna try to do it on pc
and we're gonna see somebody gonna walk
me through it i i got enough great
people around me to walk me through it
because boy sometimes i ain't so smart
but we're gonna have to figure all that
out i can't wait to play to be honest
with you man i'll be honest with you
because like i've been seeing like i saw
bg posting footage of it i saw what alex
went through i saw erica put a swordplay
a bit of it and i saw um i saw my man
eric play he played a bit of it too
it looked cool man it it's giving me
like halo 3 vibes to be completely
honest with you i haven't played it yet
so i can't really speak on it it's just
like the look and the feel and i love
the positive the reception that 343 is
getting because as we know 343 had kind
of been stumbling a little bit so it's
it's good to see that they they're
getting a positive reception in this
light yeah so what we're going to do uh
i was going to save halo infinite tech
test for last but since we've already
dug into it pretty good let's just go
ahead and talk about that first off so
let's get that out of the way
now
here's what i enjoy about this game i
enjoy the way it feels like i'm not
going to say that halo 5 was a good
multiplayer i feel like a lot of people
overlooked its multiplayer because of
how
you know underwhelming i'm not going to
say that the single player was hot
garbage because i don't think it was i
just think it was really underwhelming
and i think there was a lot of pacing
issues with it i think they were reusing
assets i don't know exactly what went
down with that game
but it was definitely interesting how
things went uh so then you know you go
there
you look at the pacing that they've put
into halo infinite in general it feels
more like the old halo games than
anything and i can respect that because
i feel like at the end of the day
that that's one of the biggest things
that matters is it matters exactly how
it feels you it's hard to really
accommodate older fans and then still
bring in
newer fans if that makes sense
yeah it does it does and i'm actually
pleased to hear that you um that you're
comparing this to the halos of the past
um
i i've been playing halo 5 with the
troubleshooters
i probably got like 10 hours in it don't
necessarily quote me on that but i have
been playing halo 5 on the xbox via game
pass and everything i'm having a blast
hopping up on the wall hog you know with
the the one that shoot rockets like yeah
i'm killing free killing frenzy all of
it all of it there all of us to me and
then capture the flag and everything
that to me is like so dope just running
that and so it's kind of like reassuring
to hear that this multiplayer so far so
so far so good like it's that's like
reassuring to hear like i'm actually
happy that they hear that because as we
know the multiplayer is free and any and
everybody can come in so i'm just
looking forward to a really good
multiplayer and um can i speak on the uh
single player for halo 5 yeah if i make
a speak on it
all right it's i figured because i
haven't i have not played it yet but i
think everybody's issue was that it was
just advertised wrong um all right smoke
kind of had spoiled it for me he's like
lock and master chief they don't really
they make it seem like they're getting
it on like they're going to really get
it on their throwhands but they kind of
don't really so maybe a little bit
well hey hey i haven't gotten through it
yet however i mean that's probably just
why people seem to be disappointed
um
the the multiplayer i i i'm like that's
something i'm anticipating to play man
like that's something i really want to
like really get in because i used to be
a halo dude like because i know people
may know me from playing a lot of games
and it was it started that started with
gears 5 by the way i played in b halo 1
i didn't play in b hello 2. i played
halo 3 multiplayer a lot like a whole
lot like when gears was out i was not
playing games i was playing halo 3. so i
mean so i got history with the game and
everything it's just
it looks like everything is going to
quote unquote come together regardless
if co-op is is there they wanting that i
think that we may not have much to worry
about um i do have a question
wouldn't you think we'll see anything in
regards to the multiplayer you don't
have to answer this right away but at
the beginning start points i i kind of
want to you mean a single player
single player yes yes sir
for some reason
i'm feeling like they about to drop that
like
you want us to single player buy the
damn game i don't know why but like i
think i i got a philly man so let's get
this flame super chat rook we got a two
dollar super chat from flame not like
the battle pass progress good game
though let's talk about that yeah
uh we'll come back to the single-player
thing here in a second um
the battle pass
i'm that's the biggest thing that
they've done i wasn't feeling the little
co-op at launch but that battle passes
when i was like
nah that's not it because to me
that's
if there's anything i hate in destiny i
know a lot of you probably don't play
destiny but i can't stand
the way destiny does like there there's
this event called iron banner it's
pretty much like where your level counts
they got like once or twice a month i
can't remember how many times but we're
going to go once or twice a month i know
that's a pretty uh wide range i don't
like the fact that they encourage you
and reward you for using other weapons
so like for instance there will be a
question destiny's like yo use you use
sidearms and then you got a bunch of
guardians walking in an iron banner that
don't like sidearms so what is that
naturally doing huh so that's making the
experience worse because people are
using guns that they don't like
so now i got the and then not to mention
if you have at least you know competent
uh teammates you you can maybe rock with
that but when you have bad teammates on
top of making them use guns they don't
want to use
what do you do you think that's a good
mixture there hustle
nah but okay so i don't play destiny so
i do have a question in regards to that
are your guns like do your guns level up
is that is that a thing the way like you
might have like a pistol but your
pistols level fight like in um no
division two just do they level up at
all not really it's really just like the
the light level like the higher light
level you are
you know every 10 light it's it's pretty
much a different bracket of damage
but
for all weapons yeah for everything
gotcha and i think that that's the
biggest thing i just i just don't like
is like that's my fear with halo we're
gonna have unbalanced teams because
you're forcing people to use weapons
they don't want to use
instead of just i can understand okay
let's let's season pass got a hundred
levels let's say you do these the you
give them the amount of experience that
you would normally give them just for
winning or participating in a match but
then if you do these daily to weekly
challenges on top of that you're
probably going to finish that season
pass a lot quicker that's the way that
it should be and that's the way that
everything does but for some reason 343
is like hold my beard let's do something
new
and i think it's going to blow up in
their face i really do like i hope they
change this this is the one thing i can
honestly say that 343 in terms of
multiplayer is dropping the ball on
because i do feel like in terms of
multiplayer we don't know about that
single player we don't know yet i feel
like they they've done everything right
but this is this is a big deal too how
they're doing the progression system
like it's equivalent hustle do they have
any weeklies or stuff in gears because i
don't play that trash multiplayer
no i don't do that don't do that but
that's that was the point that you must
be reading my mind that's the exact
point that i was about to bring up so
initially when gears first started um
you know for reference sake uh or i
guess disclosure say i got like 130
hours in gears five um pull up if you
want smoke say no no but i got 130 hours
in that and what they used to do in
order to like unlock the characters and
everything they will make you play
different modes of different games you
know what the troubleshooters we
primarily played uh king of the hill we
didn't really play tdm like that we
wasn't playing uh i think it's
escalation we wasn't playing that we
wasn't playing
like none of the other modes like even
um horde had a mode the way like if you
played with horde if you wanted to get a
lizzie elizabeth karma if you wanted to
get her you had to do all these
different things
over time and you couldn't change them
at first i don't think but over time
what happened was with giz you can press
like the x button and it'll give you
three different um objectives that you
can do or and you can keep swapping them
in and swapping them out and i think uh
halo is doing that now i think whoever
came over there because it was reported
that somebody from 343 came over there
now i don't want to assume anything but
it looked like somebody put the bug in
their ear it was like hey we do this on
our multiplayer you should do this too
and it's so trash though i i hated that
joint but guys ended up fixing it though
they ended up fixing it when you got
points for like the gangs you played and
i think haley's gonna go back to that
one i have a feeling they're going to
because i think that you see an outcry
now
but when the game comes out it's going
it's going to hit different because then
people are dealing with it and and to me
it's just like look i get it but i just
don't understand why they would even try
something like this like
now
you're not going to have people that
just want to kick it don't care to get
the challenges they know if they play
enough they're going to get to a level
100 anyway but now to my knowledge you
gotta do the weeklies and the dailies
and if you don't do the weeklies and
dailies you're never gonna get to the
end of the season pass so you're gonna
always have people trying to you know
i'm assuming they're gonna have stuff
like shoot people of rockets and shoot
people uh you know hit people with
gravity hammers you're gonna have people
camping out at the power weapons just to
get a hold of them
and it's that sound like a multiplayer
to me added they run straight toward
them power weapons they bums anyway
let me let me
get into perspective this way hustle
some people don't care
uh for instance when i'm in the hos
when i'm in in destiny they're like yo
kill people with machine gun i'm in that
i want to get this step done i don't
care if i'm contributing to the team or
not i'm in that i'ma sit by the heavy
for the last 30 seconds knowing i'm not
doing nothing for the team
and i that's my fear that's gonna happen
in this game is that people will be like
i need to get that gravity hammer i need
to get that uh you know whatever gun
that they're trying to get and they're
going to camp by where that place is
until it spawns back so now that and
it's only 4v4 so if one person does that
and there could be multiple that do that
guess what hustle it's automatically a
for a three on four or two on four and
you know
we could say both teams are gonna do
that so it's gonna kind of level out but
it's just like come on like this is such
a bad idea maybe i'm wrong maybe they
have
fixed the issue that everyone in the
industry is having in terms of
challenges and the way that they do
these kind of mission types but maybe
they found the answer i doubt it but
maybe they have i'm not gonna put too
much thought into that but how do you
feel about that
well i'll tell you um because like i
said
sadly i haven't played it yet but i saw
bg playing it and they had two gravity
hammers on the field so i don't think
it's gonna be an unbound super
unbalanced thing nowhere there's only
going to be the one thing there and it's
going to be a mad race to go get it i
think at least from according to what i
saw on one i forget what i didn't know
what the name of the map was i was just
watching the gameplay i'm saying okay
there's two of those and and if there is
one of those things there there are ways
to counteract somebody picking up um or
somebody uh like not getting a power
weapon typically in gears what i used to
do and shout out to lady fox fire in the
chat she can actually speak to this if
somebody ran into a boom or ran into a
snipe
you could pick up them joints you can
pocket them or or halo
you pick up
the gravity hammer right once you die it
drops on the field but on on gears it
didn't and i kind of wish halo would
adopt that because like a lot of people
will have like the power weapons and
obviously it does it drops when you kill
someone in halo they drop their stuff
no well that's what i mean i wish they
would kind of go against that i wish
that once you have it in your possession
and if you switch away from it can't
nobody else get it because a lot of
people do be cheesing with compiled
weapons i've done that with like frags
i've done it with i've done it with
pretty much every power weapon you could
think of because i really don't use that
you know me man this it's nasty gang all
day over here but but i used like the
basic generic weapons because like
that's how i had to learn how to play
but i mean i don't think well you know
and i know it's not a part of the halo
meta or something like that but they can
really take advantage of like these
objectives that you have in the game and
they can really like it can really be
like a super fun thing to do like
uh get like a hail mary during the match
to get experience point you could throw
a sticky grenade and try to stick you
know one two people try to stick four
people during the match or whatever case
maybe they can really have fun with it
and i can see where the fun can be had
but i don't like the fact that they
don't give you experience um i i bought
a bag of doritos today and like
for the longest time ever since my 360
days what they used to do with halo 3 in
particular maybe you remember maybe you
don't every time you buy a bag of
doritos on mountain dew or something
they were like hey use this code to get
experience from the back i would kind of
feel better with them doing that than
making you do these objectives i can
understand that you can have fun with
them but not everybody going through
that because not everybody's going to
have time to play it all day long like i
might i might be able to play halo maybe
once twice a week if anything and that's
if i'm that streamer right i might be
able to do it twice a week if if i'm
lucky
so i mean yeah so i hope they find a way
around
around cause you said you got to play it
daily to get up and if you guys
you it's not that you have to play daily
to my knowledge the only way to get xp
is to do
the daily and i don't know if there's
weekly i assume there's going to be
weekly challenges to keep doing those to
get the xp like they don't just
generally give you xp for beating the
actual mission it i mean
just for completing it and i think
that's the biggest issue because to me i
want halo to come out and be the best it
possibly can be
oh yeah i mean i think
um and this this is sad to say
um first of all shout out to what shout
out to xbox in the chat we see you boy
um this is sad to say the glory days of
halo as of right now are behind them you
remember when halo 3 came out in 2007 i
do believe
that was an event
attic are we okay yeah we're good we're
good okay okay you know that that was an
actual event i remember when that when
that dropped like that was the reason
why i had like run out there and get a
360 even though i couldn't get a day one
that was the reason that that was when
g4 tv was a thing the world stopped now
it's entirely possible for halo to have
this appeal again probably won't have it
with this game here but it's impossibly
and you know it's possibly like
plausible for them to like move like
this again because we saw you know for
better or worse we saw what cyberpunk
did um
a lot of people in in our community i
was like yo that was a whole event that
was a whole event on steam steam
crashing that was the whole thing and
i'm not saying that halo can't come back
to that i'm just saying maybe not right
now i hope they do though i hope they do
because that was the whole event man and
there's so much riding on this there's a
lot that's the one we do here yes yeah
yeah now so yeah when we hear stuff like
uh you're not having this at launch
you're not having that at launch oh you
want to play the multiplayer you got to
do this this and this you got to jump
through hoops
yeah i mean don't bother it's taking
away from the fact that it's just like
let's just play the game like and
that's my biggest fear like
i was a little upset when it come to the
the co-op experience i did feel like
that's a key component to halo but i do
understand that that is a feature it's
not like
what made halo halo
uh you know i do think it was one of the
the key features but it was a feature
they don't necessarily need that at
launch i would prefer that at launch but
who am i to tell them that they need
something that someone else might need
that you know just because i'm going to
play with you know maybe you kid smooth
doesn't mean everyone's going to and
it's kind of you know it's kind of
unfair for me to tell the people that
are going to play this game by
themselves that they got to wait three
months just because i want to play with
another person and so we got a two
dollar superchat from flame they just
need to copy
master chiefs battle pass and xp i agree
with you flame and to be honest with you
i think hustle can agree with me they're
going to fix this this isn't something
that's going to be
uh too far into the i would not be
surprised within a month of this game
coming out
they fix it because to me
this is going to be a very long
juveniled game for them and if they
don't make sure it works properly and
everyone gets what they want i do think
it's going to blow up in their face
i want to um highlight a comment from
big cloud y'all make sure y'all go
subscribe to two-bit cloud if you
haven't done so also he has agent 47 on
his podcast in the very near future
asking for details
this game has to hit on all cylinders
big clouds you are a thousand percent
right listen
mario
would not go out like this you
understand like play set or nintendo
wouldn't let mario go out like this uh
playstation
for better for worse wouldn't let the
last of us go out like this regardless
of what people may think of the last one
i mean
playstation did say we're just not going
to give you multiplayer at all and just
cut that entire thing from it so like i
don't think that's a good example hustle
because like you know nothing about you
god of war is a good example
okay now you got me on that you got me
on that but no but you can't let your
that's your baby like that i was looking
at um a video last night with adam
setzlon g4 tv and they was talking about
the birth of halo now if you're
unfamiliar with the birthday hello just
look up g4 icons with halo you'll see
how it started off as a third-person
game or i think it was a real-time
strategy and then they turned the third
person and then they put it back to
first person it was on apple it was on
back yada yada
i'm going off they went over the whole
thing like you know bungie when they
originally did it
they almost went out of business behind
that joint and like and then it turned
into microsoft's like
franchise ip and by the way it's
completely by accident people wasn't
people was not hyping halo at first i i
promised you already because i remember
that xbox launch people wasn't hyping
that
hello
yeah my my bad i i forgot it does that
like it does that
weird thing where it's like yo let's
let's let's just stop the whole
conversation for no reason i forgot to
have done that uh sorry y'all no that
that's not your fault i thought it was
just gonna add him in here but you know
uh we do got big clyde he wanted to come
through here and talk i'm fixing the
things a little bit uh you know and plus
you know big cloud whenever you get in
here definitely promote uh promote your
your
uh promote your interview man like uh
yeah you you you and jabari over here
making the iron lords podcast uh guess
like we need to step our game up like
so while we're waiting for him to do
what you uh guys are doing
we should be able to hear everyone i
don't i can't hear you [ __ ] but we'll
talk while you get that taken care of
halo is a big thing now i i will say
that i do feel like halo isn't as
important as it used to be because
that's all microsoft had
they have a little bit more to yeah we
can they have a little bit more to work
with but i will say that
in a world where they can get halo it
halo even back to a remnant of what it
used to be
in it that that is the best case
scenario for microsoft and to me it's
like
you're not showing me that you're trying
that like i feel like you you want to
go ahead and rush the product out the
door i don't know if rushing is a good
term but it's just like man this is halo
we're talking about like like let's
that's why i mean kids move we fought
over because i was like delay that
sucker let's let's wait six months i
know people don't want that delay and i
know they're gonna get clowned on but at
this point
they delayed it from the xbox series x
launch title
what is a couple more months at this
point
it's called quality control that's all
it is
but um no we've had this conversation so
many times i even said this with game on
daily on the show like
this this is your iconic
franchise like imagine if sony did this
with spider-man
and screwed up and fumbled like this you
know i'm saying that hurts the
reputation that hurts the game you want
this to launch in his best way possible
so
personally they definitely do need to
delay this game they need to go back to
the drawing board on whatever issues
that they have i'm not saying they have
to delay it by a year i'm not saying
nothing like that but i'm saying quality
control is always a must the last thing
you ever want especially for halo is to
have a situation like
wait for it
wait for it
cyberpunk
i don't want that situation i don't
think that we're nowhere near a
cyberpunk scenario but i do i think this
is just one of those things where it's
like what's best for the game not
necessarily a quality thing it's like
you know
just because there's not a co-op
experience doesn't mean the quality of
the game's not going to be there but to
have that co-op experience is going to
enhance the experience in general so
it's just like you should make sure
that's there like like as far as forge
i think six months is too long to wait
for that but three months is fine delay
that three months get that and get get
that co-op experience working and then
in three months forge drops that's fine
but like i'm just like they don't want
to delay and it's like look like as long
as the single player comes out and it's
fine i guess at the end of the day i
don't care because i i i could play it
by myself
yeah the thing the single player will
sell it but let's face it a lot of us
most of us when it came to this game and
leading up to it we were talking about
playing this and co-op or we're not oh
no that's one the key feature that's we
were talking about that's why you know i
was so vocal about this because this
like looked like i was going to play
with my brother i was going to play with
kid smooth it's like but now
none of that is an option and i get it
like i said earlier i can't say that
they need to delay this just because i
want to play it with someone when
there's probably way more people that's
going to play by themselves anyway
but you know i do want to rail this back
a little bit since you came in here
bitcloud like you know did you play the
halo infinite beta at all or the tech
test whatever the hell they're calling
it
uh not this one no not this one then i
get a chance to play it i watched
everybody else play it everybody said it
was uh good for what we saw and um it
looked fine it looks great for what
they've done so they definitely
improve the multiplayer i'm just you
know obviously when it comes out we'll
see what the main package is that's
obviously what 343's main issue has been
it's just the package they'll do good on
one thing yeah i mean but not great on
the other like we haven't seen the story
we haven't played the story all the way
so
it's up to them at this point
yeah i agree with you because i feel
like
they got a good multiplayer and they do
and and
as far as the single player
i do understand like i myself aren't too
worried about that because i know
that single player even if it's a
disappointment i know it's it to me
personally it's it's going to be like
man that was disappointing i'll say my
review but then after that review on
going back to the multiplayer i'll
probably never talk about the single
player again besides like clowning if
it's a bad single player and like a like
a party on xbox live like that
multiplayer is more important to me in
general but i do understand that the
single player is it's really important
especially from a review-wise because
that multiplayer could be great that
single player is really bad
no one's going to play that multiplayer
and you you've been talking about this
for a while too you even said on iop
like your faith in 343 is not at the
highest you know i mean it's not there
where you where it was when they first
started getting on the halo projects you
said i'm saying so you're not alone in
this conversation you see it on social
media you see it in videos i'm not
talking about playstation guys you've
seen them with xbox guys you know voice
their opinions
343 and their overall just
i would say their faith that people have
into them is not
super high
you know they're they're going into this
giving them a chance but
make no mistake about it it's like thin
ice you know this is something they have
to really knock out the they got knocked
out the park it legit dude saying that
it's going to be great because of the
multiplayer you know some people played
and said the overall package is done
because of that no no no no no
this is halo this morning just halo more
than just multiplayer this is everything
story mode everything it has to legit
deliver everything i i completely 100
are great let's get some of these super
chats out of the way we got a five uh
super chat from mr irishman personally
don't think it's bad it's too bad
especially compared to free to play
games that i think 343 has already said
they're changing it's just not for
launch
i agree i agree there man like i'm not
gonna say that you know i don't think
it's it's doom and gloom i think it is
eyebrow raising and i think that uh you
know maybe not individually these aren't
a huge deal but this is a lot of things
that they're missing at launch and i
don't think we can really say that
there's not a lot of things missing at
launch uh so we got to find out super
chat from kade forever
uh so it looks like cogs boy colin has
gotten into some significant
conversation a few days ago over
uh the
over t2
take two oh oh okay yeah let's talk
about that real quick let's all right
all right let me make sure oh man okay
all right let let me get these super
chats well no actually i don't want
let's talk about that real quick i will
get to the super chats here in a minute
what do you guys think of colin
moriarty's uh
criticism on microsoft and how they're
approaching stuff and where he says that
you know they will become the villain in
their own story they keep purchasing
big you know publishing outlets a lot of
developers you know hustle how do you
feel about that do you feel like you
know he does have a point there do you
feel like that sooner or later people
are going to start side eyeing it's like
you know you're not trying to nurture
anything you're just trying to take
content away from people
um that's kind of what i said the cog
like before but um i i'm treating grand
theft auto like just just talk about the
grand theft auto thing apple tree grand
theft auto like it's minecraft right you
said how minecraft is still available
anywhere else you want to go play it if
that acquisition were to happen
grand theft auto or whatever other game
whatever other big game that they got
over there take two dumb joints still
going to be available everywhere so i
not heard what colin said i respectfully
disagree he has of course he's entitled
to his opinion but there is no way that
microsoft turns down that type of money
you we just saw grand theft auto sell
like 150 million grand the 105. i just
saw 150 mil though you think they're
going to just get that up just to say oh
we got an exclusive over here yeah
microsoft might got the money for but
that ain't stupid they'll never make
their return on their investment buying
a studio like that ever no not at all
that's why like yo if if they do it
it'll it'll still be available
everywhere all will be
yeah i mean
not to mention like
besides gta what does take two even have
to offer like that like you know what
i'm saying like maybe maybe uh you know
the 2k franchise like like that's all
but the 25k franchise comes with
licensing headaches too it's not like
like you only just get that and you get
constantly make that like to me the only
thing that take two got going for them
like going going for them is that gta
franchise and i'm not saying i know that
the chat's already getting there they're
already about to say some stuff and what
about
borderlands i'm not saying that they
don't own stuff or they help publish
stuff that's good games i'm saying in
terms of quality and the value that
microsoft would be looking for gta would
be the only thing that would be of a
significant value to buy a company like
that and to me
to me um
i'm gonna ask you guys
wouldn't it be just cheaper to give them
a couple billion dollars and just make
that timed exclusive like
it's just like it makes no sense to buy
that whole that whole company like there
is so much more companies out there that
microsoft can get their foot in
to actually benefit them wb
yeah i've been saying wb games to
counter insomniacs spiderman and
wolverine we've been talking about this
for a while they need a superman you
know superhero game to combat spiderman
why not have something like that had
that be your poster boy something you
could put on banners everywhere around
the world and go hey guys guess what
superman exclusive xbox batman exclusive
xbox
you know what i'm saying
i said it last week i said listen man
sometimes you gotta play that game right
along with them they can have it oh you
see you know what murphy said that last
week that's what i said right because
square enix can't do it right y'all you
see that he'll just they can't do it
right what is sony doing somebody's
building their own they're doing
wolverine they're gonna have the x-men
be thrown into this then they're gonna
merge them
that's what they're doing that's the
long-term goal they're they're trying to
replicate what you're seeing in the
movies but bring it in game form why
isn't microsoft doing that with like
batman v superman i would buy that for
an xbox i would buy that on the xbox
platform
i agree with stuff like that i feel like
i don't personally want them to go down
that direction i want them to nurture
the stuff they have now i don't want
them expanding anymore unless it's sega
because i feel like sega actually
contributes to problems that they
actually have and i think that if they
bought sega it would help with the
eastern market that they're getting
destroyed in like obliterated change the
narrative because the name recognition
alone will push them and they will be
able to get out there even more but
buying take two um
does nothing it's just literally
like opening a pothole and throwing
money in it
it's like you'll never see the return on
your investment unless sony budgets and
goes hey yeah well that game pass on our
playstation that way you'll make your
money back because gta will be
everywhere they'll make their money
through them shark cards and all that
stuff because that's what they tried to
do even with red dead 2 with the gold
bar system and that didn't work so
you'll never see it returning your
investment with something like a rock
star all right so yeah those kids
i definitely want to back this up
because we kind of like went sideways
off the off of with the actual like
in terms of what colin actually liked
the contents behind his statement do you
guys think that if they did buy take two
and they did buy uh you know uh
publishers like sega and let's say they
did buy wb let's say next week they come
in like we bought take two we buy sega
we bought wb
how do you think
everyone would react to that do you
think that people would start to say
that you're trying to monopolize the the
industry in general do you think that
they would indeed start to become a
villain because me personally i do feel
like if they start
buying first off let's just be real here
microsoft's got one big publisher before
the government start to shut them out of
the industry like they got one more they
buy a wb maybe more if they bought wb
because i feel like wb's getting out so
it's different than just
buying something they buy sega they're
not buying anything else i don't think
the government's going to let them
and to me like i feel like colin's not
wrong
in a point because i feel like colin's
point is like look like
they need to nurture their own stuff and
at the end of the day all you're doing
is you're just taking away cookies from
other people like what you need to be
doing is nurturing the stuff that you
currently have and offer original
cookies from your own kitchen to your
consumers and not just take cookies from
other people and i feel like that's what
he's saying and if you keep going down
this direction you'll eventually be the
villain in everyone's story what do you
feel about that [ __ ]
so that's a that's a good point i agree
we definitely that's that's definitely
the case here because everybody again
when you look at what sony has to offer
especially for 2023 going onwards
especially going before you even get
there every single thing that's being in
the timeline is from ps4 we already got
build up to these sequels we had stuff
already built up towards when you look
at microsoft there's not really that big
luxury of let's say an option right they
just bought these studios and said hey
guys
um this game was multiplat it's on our
platform now you get you have to go here
that will eventually happen where people
will go listen um it's cool that you're
part like that this would be the
narrative it's cool that you're a part
of the studio
but what exactly are you doing when's
this game dropping because that's what
everybody wants everybody wants results
at this point you already got bethesda
we don't have those games yet see what
i'm saying you buy let's say you they
bought take two and uh what games you
say you said wb take two and one up so
they bought those studios everybody
immediately is gonna look at them and go
well [ __ ] um that's cool but
where's my games where's the results and
then
another thing that comes with these
studios again is quality quality control
take two
launched ww2k in the worst state
possible oh boy
i don't think anybody wants to ever look
at 2k games the same
i don't know if y'all saw the trailer
for the new game it looks exactly the
same as the one before they said it's
different i'm my bro yeah aew is about
to give you an even bigger run for your
money with use
we we can have that conversation a
little bit cloud yeah yeah aw from the
yeah it's not even a competition
no it's not even a competition the ogs
are back and they about to take that
throne from them so it's like yeah
what do you gain yeah that that free
ride is over hey um addict i i swear man
colin must listen to the show because i
swear i swear i could've told you
incognito this last week man look i
think cognito had posed the question yo
should they buy more should they buy
more i said nah they need to nurture
their own talent like playstation dude
though like there's a reason why like we
we see these up and coming stupid like
we see a game like kendall right for all
of his quote-unquote flaws in it
if the playstation decides to buy ember
lab studios and they nurture that talent
right then you got another insomniac on
your hands like this is just based off
of rough draft based off of a game that
everybody seems to be high on i only
played a little bit of it so i'm not
gonna get too much into it but like they
just gotta learn how to nurture talent
um i think bond had made um have made
this comparison on weapon wheel this
past sunday and i made a comparison
before as well
xbox is like
daniel snyder who's the owner of the
washington football team
back in the day all he would do he would
sign these big free agents and you would
have a team of superstars and they
wouldn't even make the playoffs
yeah i'm more concerned about stuff like
that yes sir see let me address the chat
because they're saying that what if sony
sony would do it no i'm not saying sony
wouldn't buy stuff they had the luxury
but i'm saying when you when you look at
the way sony's been moving they're not
trying to buy super huge known companies
like that they're really buying
companies that
work with them the best for example
insomniac that just i don't see insomnia
with another company besides so let's
tell me let me push back
okay uh i honestly and truly do feel
like sony's not in the first off sony
was embedding war for the people that uh
tinsen bought um the one that had
warframe and stuff so
they do want these companies they're
just not outbidding the people winning
these bits like
and that's not a bad thing you know
you know when when we you know sony
right there was trying i mean they would
own splash damage if they won that bit
uh they're trying to correct mistakes
that people want they want more
multiplayer games and that company was
the king of that [ __ ] so you know
that's why i'm saying like i'm let me
address the chat real quick i'm not
saying microsoft not to buy anything
i'm saying they need to lay off the
publishers because to me
the only way the only time that i would
say it's okay to buy something at this
point is if it fixes something that
that's broken if they can get
netherrealm from wb games to make killer
instinct it fixes something that is
broken if they can get
you know rocksteady from wb games and
make some kind of comic book game it
fixes something that is broken if they
can get sega to make sure they have some
kind of stance in the eastern part of
the world it fixes something that is
broken
by take two fixes nothing
it just adds on to the portfolio that
they already have
so i said this nurture crap this bs you
won triple a games you buy triple a
games ain't got no time for nurture uh
listen man
i don't wanna i don't i don't know how
to really tackle that got that comment
um
there's always time to nurture our
studio
okay now i will say he has
he does have
some some valid in that like i think his
point is like look
sony was nurturing studios and microsoft
wasn't so it's just like
they're using their money to try to
bridge that gap a little bit to try to
buy studies that's already been nurtured
from other companies and i think that's
his point it's like look like the
nurturing thing isn't a hundred percent
there and it's not it's like i said they
just they try to buy the people who who
own warframe so like they they didn't
nurture that company they've never they
prob besides marketing does they
probably never even talked to that
company like that so it's like you know
i definitely understand that point and i
understand that when you when you didn't
take this that as serious as sony took
it for so many years
you're gonna have to spend money to make
up that difference i can just be real
with you it's like it's like
d uh it's like dc and marvel marvel
built and nurtured a very enticing and
very appealing
movie industry for years 10 15 years
dc
refuses to do that
they try to
cut shortcuts
and you know it's it's like that is like
equivalent to
they're not doing the things that needs
to be done to fix the issues but
microsoft's like look like we're not
going to go the dc route and just try to
throw out content that appeals to
certain people we're going to buy
companies that actually have very
nurtured studios and is actually going
to benefit us in the long run now i feel
like bethesda was a good get they needed
that they needed those western studios
and they needed those adult rated
western studios there's no longer that
narrative where microsoft only makes
kitty games because there is nothing
about star field obviously we don't know
a lot about starfield but i think we can
all agree on this battle it's not gonna
look like sea thieves
uh whatever whatever the doom uh
the doom people i think it's id they're
not gonna work on some kitty game so i
do think that fixed an issue and that
was a huge issue for years but as far as
continuously expanding and areas that
they don't need
microsoft doesn't need no more western
support they got the whole western
support
they got it all like in terms of western
rpgs there's like four big companies
they don't own at this point
yeah uh enemy heavy i don't know if you
got like a vendetta or something like
that microsoft did that before sony did
it as well
buying a time exclusivity yeah
and i actually i feel i feel like they
need to what are we doing here i feel
like they need to re-engage that type of
practice to be honest with you so you
want more timed versions
i want more timed exclusives until these
studios are ready
because i feel like you know clearly
you're not going to be able to get the
avows the fables
etc that are out by next year and this
is exactly what happened with sony i
will get to the super chats i know
they're adding up i'm apologizing it's a
good conversation and i want to you know
uh disrupt the flow of the conversation
so
my sony a couple years ago i'm assuming
they're like look
after these last little bit of games
come out for playstation we're kind of
[ __ ] out of luck for a little bit
because they're re-shoot they they're
redeveloping newer games so let's worry
chapter the square enix and let's get
all this [ __ ] like
it's like let's get the final fantasy 7
remix let's get the remake part 2 let's
get the 16s let's get the forsakens
let's get those to sprinkle where our
other stuff isn't to
bridge that gap to make it easier and
more justified to buying a playstation
and keeping a playstation because that's
part of the game too not only are they
trying to sell to a new audience they're
trying to keep the the older audience
that already bought their platform from
selling to someone else because then
they're not getting that money
so you know and i think that's what
microsoft should have done they should
have looked at what comes out next year
and like look like what can we do to get
this game overall it doesn't even have
to be a long i've always said it and
i'll say it over and over again
timed exclusives matter
as long as they are actually relevant
tomb raider was a good timed exclusive
but they let that to die with one of the
biggest games that came out last
generation which was fallout 4. i myself
might not have liked fallout 4 to the
point where everyone else did but i'm
not going to act like it that wasn't a
juggernaut game and had no business
being nowhere near fallout 4. the right
timed exclusive matters look what
happened with final fantasy vii they got
that timed exclusive one of the biggest
games that came out last year or the
year before i can't remember when the
initial one came out and then guess what
happened six months to a year they
launched a big dlc that was just as big
as the original one and sony got two
forms of time exclusivity for the price
of one
i'm saying build upon it makes sense
but we we're not seeing the yeah we need
more of that we we need microsoft to
want to fill those gaps and i will say
to a point game pass does help with that
because i was talking to cognito this
morning before he went to bed i was like
the thing that's interesting is how
they're taking about this the thing
that's interesting is you know people
that don't game on
xbox regularly you don't see the amount
of content they're always throwing in
that game pass because you're just
seeing the the tweet every every half a
month every 15 days but when you keep
adding those games up throughout the
months
if i wanted when i get mad bored and i
have nothing to play guess what i do i
go look at game pass and i can guarantee
you even my
ass could find something relatively
quick there so these super chats get
ridiculous let's let's catch up with
these
we got a five dollar super chat from uh
uh fastio seven butchered that we're
moving past it how is halo uh situation
is equal to cyberpunk please explain the
multiplayer is the most taxing out of
all the xbox machines and they run good
uh that was something big cloud said i
don't think he was saying that it's
going to be that i think he was saying
let's avoid that control yeah let's
avoid that
we're trying situations somewhere yeah
we're trying to avoid something like
that happening i think that was his
point on that
uh has you got anything to say about
that hustle or is that pretty
self-explanatory no no we can move on we
can move on from now we got a five
dollar super chat from rubber knob
i love that damn
the single player is as important as the
multiplayer mode if it is a 10-year plan
on both story and multiplayer i
completely agree with you robert i was
saying me particularly in my opinion i
love the single player and i love the
lore of halo but what keeps me coming
back to halo is the multiplayer and i
think for the most part we could all
agree with that like i i'm not saying
that multiple that single player isn't
important because it is i'm saying to me
personally
i
knocked that single player out in a
couple days and i rarely go back to any
single player and what's keeping me on
88 of the time is the multiplayer but
it's like i said if that single player
doesn't hit right that that metacritic
score would be drastically impacted
so we got a
five dollar superjet from lucas
augustus lucius augustus okay i
butchered that that's fine though you
guys know this we're moving past it
shout out to addix world salute to the
iop persona on xbox let's go
okay let's let's put another hold on
these super chats for a couple seconds
for the people in my comment section
tell me persona 5 is never coming to
xbox when they announce that coming
because i'm confident it is i want these
people in this chat and i want some into
the bushes for these people into this
chat because just because you personally
don't think something's coming doesn't
mean it's not coming
so
okay i'll say this before you move on if
we see
the whole yakuza series on xbox
then it you know nothing would
particularly stop persona and uh
obviously if
xbox buys or microsoft buys sega and
we're definitely seeing that yeah no i
think that's the thing i think i think
that's going to happen regardless
whether they make that acquisition than
that though i think i think because then
i think it's going to be a thing let me
let me ask you a bit cloud let me ask
you a question be in the uh
uh the
the prominent playstation channel and
shout out to your hitman uh
uh interview that you're about to do
so thank you
question to you if microsoft at e3
because i don't think it would ever
happen at the tokyo game show which i
already made a video about that
definitely go check that out if you guys
want to see my thoughts on what's going
to be at the tokyo game show but let's
say microsoft comes out at e3 and they
announce
let's say they show persona 6.
let's say you know it's just persona 6
there and at the end they say they
bought sega and it's
exclusive
do you feel like that is a good movement
in the way direction that they actually
need or do you think that's being too
aggressive and it's not helping their
overall ecosystem
you said earlier when you have a problem
you have to throw money in to fix that
problem their biggest issue is over
there in the western territories one
night they have issues
so them buying sega would help them a
lot okay so
i see it yeah that makes sense
and that's all my point is like their
persona is coming like just like hustle
said regardless but i don't think people
understand
exactly
microsoft is throwing money and i get it
it's like call and said like they
they're not nurturing studios and i'm
not necessarily saying they're not
nurturing studios but they're not
nurturing students from years of work
uh you know i would say they nurture i
would say they they nurtured but that's
the damn straight they nurtured bethesda
they like what you know how i knew they
had a great relationship when
when um todd howard said when the uh
when the the
when fallout 76
came out so busted and so messed up the
first call he made was phil spencer
like so that that shows me that they had
a great relationship and that they
probably constantly there there's
interviews where they said that they
were having a hard time getting oblivion
or it was neither oblivion or it was um
morrowind it was one of those
hard time running it on the xbox
they actually flew out engineers from
the xbox to help them get that game
running so i do think that you know
there is a lot of nurturing that
happened between bethesda and microsoft
and it was a lot more you know natural
than people think so we got a 10
subtract from rubber not sony is trying
to buy every big game for exclusive
rights permanently or just one year it's
all the same i think microsoft buying
the building is the is the way
of
combating sony with less backlash i
would agree with them to a point now i
don't
i think microsoft's buying
i mean i don't know he might have a
point there because they were going to
bethesda and they got two of them they
tried to get starfield so he might have
a point oh he is he walking he's like oh
you you tell me sony's over there
getting stuff yeah done over we buying
that stuff for all we knew
microsoft snatched that right before the
deal was done for starfield
now imagine if they didn't buy bethesda
or they bought them later enough and not
only is death philippe and ghost wire at
times exclusive for playstation so is
starfield that would be horrible
so
we got a five dollar superchat from mr
irishman with crystal d
crystal you guys are ridiculous
oh my god man this is gonna this ain't
leaving is it like you guys are gonna
say crystal d for a while the initiative
partnering and avengers coming to game
pass do you think it's a sign of a
bigger partnership with square maybe
final fantasy vii remake on game pass
no i don't think that's happening i
don't know if you guys want to tune in
for that
what the mind chris for them no that
final fantasy 7 might be coming to xbox
and game pass
uh
with the way sony's been working with
them and the deal they've been doing and
whatnot i don't see it personally i
don't see it happening at all
i personally think
my father
about this before too like if
normally those deals are one year like
we still haven't heard anything about um
final fantasy 7 coming to xbox at all
have we
have we heard any yeah so we still ain't
and it's been all this time afterwards
so probably not probably not
yeah i'll be i'll be surprised i would
be surprised
all right so we uh we got uh my favorite
uh
name jacob is the show we got a ten
dollar superchat from jw as a show how
can you sit there and say that sony
wouldn't buy big studios if they had
that money they would had sony bought
xenomax crickets sony has not built all
their studios from the ground up all
right before you say something big cause
i know you're gonna say something to
that
there is
some points behind this this
individual's super chats and i will
agree
that the reason we don't see sony buying
companies such as xenomax is because
they only got timed exclusive money they
don't got buying studio money and i
think we can agree with that when you
need billions and billions and billions
of dollars to buy some of these studios
but your whole but you you literally
have that much money in like in cash and
that's all
and and for the people that say sony has
the money to buy some of these studios
and some of these publishers but it
would literally take all of the money
they have on standby to do these things
and no
investors are going to sign off on
spending all of their their their laying
around money on one thing
yep
so you got nothing to say to that
statement oh i was very i was waiting
for you to finish no no no no no
okay so he said sony would not or sony
would buy the studios yeah that is true
sony would buy a studio like xenomax if
they had the crazy funding to do
something like that no one's denying
that but the thing about sony and
they've always done this you can't take
this away from them every game whether
it be in a time exclusive that end up
becoming a full-fledged exclusive down
the road whatever they build upon they
legit nurtured they went through
everything for that's the one thing
that's the one luxury that playstation
gamers can say about first party as well
in the playstation ecosystem every game
has a game
that has you know the day built on
to the future spider-man 2 is the
biggest game to look out for in 2023.
2024 2025 whatever
wolverine drops is the other
you can't say that for xbox not can you
all you can say is halo gears and forza
now you're throwing these other games
with studios that just got bought so
but besides wolverine
we have a last of us remake
spider-man 2
and most likely another ratchet and
clank in development i i like we can't
just say that halo gizmo is the one that
you know besides goes to shima what
uh his new little uh his little twist on
even though the dudes are gonna buy them
they they claim they they buy these ones
which is uh
funny sell to me
keep in mind uh keep them on bitcoin we
another god of war coming
yeah
so
you already knew you already knew both
studios do you already know
look i will say
how many yeah how many gears how many
gears have we had so how many uncharters
do we have buddy i mean how many halos
have we have the original god awards do
we have buddy
how many gran turismo buddy
buddy what we got but here's the thing
though you only got three
we got one and three over there on the
play station to get your toes on the
frame yeah yeah that's ideal push we got
more than three homies and not only that
yeah they get you quiet we got more than
three we got one just so halo gears and
fourths uh we got the play
um
you you can take the grand trick you can
take well you got the horizon you can
take the grand trip you got it you could
take the
the channel one there you go
there you go
yeah you like that one they like them
i i do have a comment to make in regards
to that um not only do they have the
games that big cloud just mentioned but
naughty dog pretty much it's certain
studios that i don't gotta question what
they do naughty dogs know ip gonna hit
for something different too i i don't
got no doubt in my mind i have a savage
starlight i really think of savage star
like that game that was in last that
little comic book coming to you doing
last of us i think that might be the
game it's a sci-fi like adventure action
game something like that they're making
endurance survive no no i beat that game
big club i cry like a little baby at
part one i beat that game i know what's
up i'm i'm looking forward to that
that's something i'm looking forward to
so we got a 20 super chat from drawn nti
it would not be a monopoly because it's
not closed off in in one ecosystem it's
on pc phone and xbox and soon tv
uh because if that's not true that would
be uh that they would be in court i
think look i'm not gonna say that you're
not wrong on that last time i talked
about something that i wasn't really
educated and i got roasted for so i'm
done with that life
uh to me
i don't think they have a like even any
form of monopoly because sure it was a
big publisher but i don't think that
bethesda not being on a playstation is
really affecting the board now it is
taking pieces off the board but it's not
affecting the board it's not like they
took like a rock they didn't take like
the queen you know what i'm saying like
and that that's that's my point there
but i do feel like
when microsoft if microsoft buys another
publisher like eight nine developers
governments are gonna start looking at
them a little bit like i really do i
really think that
so phil really is banking for sewing in
the cave and go hey game pass on play
that's what he really wants he's like he
really wants that blade doesn't want to
say it's not going to come to
playstation he wants jim to to crack so
bad on him he might though he cracked on
everything else yeah it just depends
they get something that that he values
more than he values come thank you guys
i don't know sega might change
i think sega you know we we can pause
the super chats for a couple seconds um
what company i think we brought this up
with the hustle i think if they bought
score enix it's a wrap
if they found a way to get square enix
the next day sony's saying game pass was
coming to their platform
they would lose all the final fantasy
they lose the dragon quests they would
lose all the publishing arms to that
because then they would go to somewhere
else that's not as friendly with them as
score 8 would be i feel like that is the
one company where it's it's a rat like
it's it's
yeah because sony formed a capital
alliance with um
uh the studio i think it's from software
right that makes uh bloodborne
yeah yeah
they became shareholders in that company
now they own like one percent in the
company so they formed a capital
alliance with them and
they're so close with capcom i could see
those two if they ever came down to like
a merger type thing if capcom everyone
do it the reason why i say capcom is
because of street fighter and what they
did last time with street fighter plus
y'all know sony bought evo
yeah
yeah and evil and they've been pushing a
lot of torment especially on their webs
on their um youtube channel you see them
playing a bunch of like mortal kombat
attacking sevens uh being now being
showcased
i would be surprised the band guy and
namco also join or they do something
with the band the guy namco but that's
what it looks like sony would do for it
but as far as
cracking uh yeah square endings would
probably be
that probably be the one because
um yeah so we got a 20 super chat from
raiden blade what are the uh what are
the difference between who who sony buys
and who microsoft buys if sony had
bought zenimax no ps fan would be upset
colin and the cast pointed out studios
that uh xbox bought why ninja theory why
double fine because these companies i
will say he was a little out of the
pocket talking about certain studios
like that uh because you know it's kind
of seemed like he didn't care about
those studios but it doesn't necessarily
mean no one cares about those studios
but that's pretty much all going on
there it's like i said i agree with a
lot what colin said uh but there are a
couple things that he said that i'm like
okay maybe that's more of your opinion
and not necessarily what was good for
their business
uh
no he was gonna uh what was he gonna say
hustle
well i thought the reason why it wasn't
microsoft was buying all these companies
wasn't due to like playstation i thought
we saw amazon kind of put their foot in
in the race yeah amazon was trying to do
it yeah and uh
google was it was it google was google
fiber for yeah
yeah for stadia so like when i see these
acquisitions
i think less play shouldn't let think
less playstation and think more about
what could have been so i mean yeah but
no but the government probably wanted to
get involved at some point it's better
i would trust the studios with microsoft
or a playstation before i ever trust
them with an amazon or a or google
especially cool yeah look what they did
to youtube you expect them to do a
studio right
look what they did to youtube no i don't
trust them with with any of these uh
with these studios i'm still shocked
that sony allowed the studio behind um
the order 1886 to get acquired by amazon
you remember that that studio was right
honestly
um
vr games i honestly felt like out of all
the studios that sony's dropped the ball
on that that radio dawn was the one that
dropped the ball the most like yeah i
felt like ready at dawn sure did they
make the most amazing game uh with the
order 1886 no and to this day that's one
of the only playstation games i didn't
play because i just didn't see
a point in me i didn't like it i didn't
like anything i saw it
yeah don't let the link conversation
fool you
hustle will tell you that game has the
best werewolf transformations i have
seen in a video game it is that well
done it is so dark has the perfect world
it has the perfect setting the problem
was is the execution especially the boss
fights i was expecting that's what i was
about
those boss fights were fleshed out kind
of like a demon souls type of esque
where you can dodge you know pair you
know do something like that maybe that
would imagine that they would have done
wonders for it but they didn't do that
what i wanted from them i think that's
what killed the game because i'm a huge
boss fight nerd and when i saw like the
same motion go around them like i didn't
like that like imagine if it would have
been something like like the underworld
where like you know the the dude at the
end of the one of the underworlds where
he could evolve one arm or one limb and
then only that limb it's like imagine
like fighting something like that kind
of like they should have like insomnia
helped to make the boss fights like now
they would redo that because i feel like
insomniac is doing set pieces in a new
unique way that looks good
you know what i think really hurt that
game though because that game was more
so like a tech demo s game for the ps4
when it first dropped right and i think
it got delayed right it got delayed for
a year or so for it the delay kind of
hurt it more so because that game was
supposed to be a attack the mls but
uh
i look back at that game then i look
back at until dawn i just go damn these
games are so
good in the visual aspect and what they
were able to accomplish
but
it is a travesty that we're we're not
going to see um a sequel i'll say this
to wrap it up yeah yeah they're working
over yeah but that's so crazy to me i'll
just say this to wrap it up attic you
got that game play that game graphically
that joint looked insane though still
holds up still yes
i'm super late it but it's a nice little
short compact game um you might not like
the boss fights but you'll like the
actual encounters and everything goes
right you'll like the weapons remember
the thermal weapons the correct yes the
thermite the arc the electric arc oh bro
they did some wild stuff with that game
though
it's good it's good i'll stand behind
that one i definitely stand behind that
one yeah i'm still the gasp um the gas
powered falcon which like it pushed them
back to stun them like they had a lot of
cool stuff in that game in that game
it's like
yeah how did you mess this up i never
know i'll
yo that could have been their you know
you know what's funny also that could
have been their gears counter
a horde mode a horde mode type of game
or a multiplayer type of mode for that
werewolves versus humans
oh that was that exact comparison
yeah that that would have been good so
let's let's go ahead and move on because
i do
i'm gonna have to merge these other two
topics because these super chats have
happened they've had actually really
good conversations in these super chats
uh so we got five dollar super chat from
jw is a shell i love that damn day
uh sony gets a pass for stuff microsoft
does complain about xbox not compete uh
competing they start competing now it's
how they are going about it cut it out
yeah like um i can if i can vouch for
you and say that that is wrong i haven't
seen that many people without talk that
much about xbox when they weren't doing
things right
i will say
that people for a long time said
microsoft's got all this money and
they're not doing nothing with it and i
will say that
every time microsoft especially that is
the thing the only thing you saw is
you know why they need that why don't
they know no change their own studio
like you know you can't just buy things
like there was a lot of contradicting
statements going on not saying was
everybody but there are people that were
saying stuff like that
um so we got raiden blades with the five
super chat sony uh sorry get your facts
straight sony started this against sega
tomb raider belong to the sega platform
only for core to be paid by sony
that feels like it's before my time i
was alive for back then but i was
definitely not of a mindset that i'm in
now when it comes to playing these games
but it does look like hustle got
something to say because he was pointing
at the screens
okay so i i do remember that and i do
remember tomb raider being it on both
platforms but i remember most of the
marketing going to a playstation um i
didn't know no better back in the day
until i started doing research on it i
thought tomb raider was only on
playstation i was gonna say yeah it was
on sale yeah i didn't know i had no idea
yeah i i literally had no idea until i
you know just started to i mean [ __ ]
tony had uh gta as well exclusive to ps2
but until it eventually went to xbox but
the funny thing is you didn't know that
much until later on that it was on xbox
when it eventually did drop
so we got a
yeah it's that's uh i'm trying to make
sure because uh yeah okay ray so we got
a two dollar switch from k forever damn
i got everyone's blood boiling yeah you
definitely started uh you definitely
started some stuff man but it's okay
like hold on i definitely i don't want
his blood boy you gotta see him play me
and him have to play uh what's that game
among us then you'll see his bloodborne
yeah
hey no no but we can't act like that one
time you didn't see me kill someone
right in front of you and i convinced
you it wasn't me
yeah so the damn game glitches uh hustle
this is funny yourself the game glitches
okay the door the door is like closed he
he shuts the door like by the dumpster
no my my partner shut the door i didn't
shut up somebody shut the door yeah and
i'm sitting there going wait did i see
somebody get killed i saw like a hand
and i heard that
like the body went up somebody's body
but i'm like going your attic that
looked very similar to you was that you
used to go no no why is it oh
no i didn't always i agree
here here's how i play among us for
people on the chat i'm always at 100. it
don't matter if i'm if i'm the villain
if i'm not the the imposter i could
literally just be a crew member and if
you come at me acting like i am the
villain i'ma come at you like i'm the
imposter always every time that way you
never know if i'm the imposter or not
and you gotta admit that that was
sometimes
that works that it does work
you do you do the most sus stuff when
you're it though like i'm talking he
does something simple just not move i'm
sitting going attic uh you know there's
a task you should be doing right you
over here just looking at people like i
know
am i okay he's it
so we got a five dollar super shot from
alvin sony wants exclusives to sell
boxes microsoft wants publishers to have
a constant supply of content so the game
pass two different strategies we compare
them too much i will agree he does have
a question that i agree it's two
different strategies and we've said for
a while uh you know microsoft's still in
the car the console making business but
it's not their focus anymore they're
focused
they want recurring revenue through game
pass and the only way to do that is to
supply the content their focus now is
game pass and
the console is a pillar that you have
access to game pass
uh i think we got one more man uh
make sure
so we got a five dollar subject from
geekhead188
why do playstation fans like to cry a
lot
i mean
like we we can't be let's be no no let's
be a hundred oh
no let's be let's be a hundred minutes
no
these playstation fanboys do be in these
spaces
these playstation fanboys live in these
spaces they don't ever leave them i wake
up someone's doing the spaces on my
xbox's jog i go to sleep someone's doing
a spaces on why xbox is bad for business
i get i get off of work someone's doing
his spaces i want xbox's dog [ __ ] it is
literally like this 24 7. they never
leave this
hold up hold up i'm about to look right
now let's see if someone is doing the
spaces right now luke is doing one right
now look at my xbox oh
look how many spaces is going on right
now
yo luke is doing what there is
there's three spaces going on right now
i would argue i would argue what luke is
doing right now she's actually doing
god's work uh with everything that just
happened today i think she's actually
the right reason
i i didn't see who it was and who it
wasn't but all i've said is
look some people do do good spaces there
was a good space i did with you know who
who's a good space uh
if you you you're really interested in
games if you see chris righteous and you
know i threatened to kill the dude a
couple years ago for those who don't
know that so you know
you
know
people are going to bring that up with
the comment section i might as well say
yes i did i apologize for it let's move
on he does good spaces if you like like
breaking down games because he really
goes into a lot but uh you know we have
one more super chat no no well not
anymore
so uh
we have a five dollar super shot for ray
and blade the government won't get
involved this is why the grazer group
that has 80 plus studios and tencent has
more until the government got involved
yeah i agree with you that like it look
i don't know a lot about stuff like that
we don't have to like a laurier on here
that's in copyright for me to know
anything like that and then we got a two
dollar super chat from raiden blade
point uh
uh point monkey c monkey dude keep that
same energy
yeah so i think he's just saying
when you see one company do something
then you know another company always do
we see it all the time like rumble uh
company saw something oh that looks cool
let's still
i would disagree because nintendo is
still far behind
yeah
which which is weird because they
innovated a lot of stuff like well i
guess that memory card
you ready to pay fifty dollars for that
again i'm gonna pay fifty dollars
i collect these too before i sit up here
and pay for that nintendo service i know
we got her move on i'm buying the games
all right from like dk ulti dkodies a
stone stone aged gamer what have you i'm
i'm buying these joints to own like you
can't even own them titles though like
that that's a service you won't even own
them joints like nah i can't do it okay
how much more it is like i'd rather just
already buy whatever i want to go get at
that point all right so man
look the kind of you guys
you guys look at rough you guys know i
don't know i didn't want to see it i
don't want to see it also but it was
looking kind of spooky you guys know i
don't like keeping these too long so
what we're going to do
i'ma rearrange the title because i do
feel like we talked about that calling
thing i need to exchange one of these
titles for that calling uh response uh
we're going to talk about
xbox
2022
and the xbox studio breakdown at the
same time
i'm going to merge those in one topic
now because i feel like if we talk about
the breakdown we're talking low key
about the 2022 odd and what that's
looking like so what what i'm going to
do the only reason
i didn't just can this top is because i
already got it up oh they got the but
that's the studio's in here now they
didn't have that for a while all right
so let me go ahead and uh i'll give the
chat this now we don't have to go into a
great detail there's something that you
know you guys want to talk about you
know just let me know so here's what
we're looking at you guys so you can
definitely bring this up what i want to
do is i want to talk about
these studios uh
uh hustle
bit the link is in the chat so you could
look at it too so we're to go through
here now there's obviously some of here
we're not going to talk about you know
maybe we'll even bring it up a little
bit you know talk about what they should
work on next because there are some that
we know and there's some that we don't
know what they're doing so 343
industries hustle what are they doing
next you think they should let's say
that halo isn't the thing what should
they do after halo hustle what is your
personal opinion
if if it don't hit something new
so
you get you get 343 away from it i don't
care what it is but you get you get
three foot three away from it and if it
don't hit if it don't if it does hit
them you know
keep on with halo but if it don't hit
you give it to somebody else but you
you do some rearranging in terms of
management i'll make this quick do some
rearranging and turn them in terms of
management and then you let them create
what they want to create i truly feel
like they're burnt out and i will leave
it at that i'll probably make a video on
it but i think 343 is burnt out with the
halo series what do you feel like [ __ ]
club
i agree with hustle i definitely agree
with hustle um if it doesn't uh hit on
all cylinders like we just said earlier
at the start of this show
um
it's time to give them their passion
project whatever the hell they need to
work on let them
be creative let them make something that
might be a sleeper hit like bungee one
to make with destiny when that end up
being a big deal you said i'm saying
maybe they can make something better let
the studio thrive i have to agree with
you guys i feel like
343 is a talented studio and we give
them a lot of [ __ ] for them working on a
game that i'm not necessarily not
passionate about but it's not their game
i feel like if you give this this studio
the free reigns to make a game that they
want to make and i'm not saying that
they don't want to make halo they signed
up to to make halo i'm saying that if
you ask a lot of the people there i'm
sure that they have a lot of creative
ideas that could generate a game that
could be that game if you give them that
opportunity
so world's edge uh they make the age of
empires like i know you guys probably
don't care about this studio does anyone
did anyone play age of empire
i didn't i saw it and just you know it's
one of those games you see it you just
kind of like dismiss it in your mind you
don't really care for a type of thing
i'd like for them to make something like
gears tactics like a like a turn-based
grid space thing like i i think the rts
is irrelevant but i'm kind of like
moving away from those in my life like
age of empires is probably a bigger
brand and they should probably keep
working on that but to me i'm more
interested in those type of games like
xcom than i am in rts is like i used to
be in my younger days
yeah
coalition what's they doing guys we're
gonna start with hustle hustle i know
you're a big fan of gears i know you
love the gears franchise what do you
feel like they should do with this
franchise with this company with this
developer
you wrap up the story to gets
no more gears no more we just talked
about game burnout i feel like they they
had enough
you excuse me you let them create
something else at this point we've
already seen what they can do with the
unreal engine i i uh and with third
person and the third person game like i
felt like they should have been the ones
to remake perfect duck in my humble
opinion they should have made it third
person as well but that's just my
opinion but you give them something else
too i feel like they have enough studios
and enough talent to where they can try
something new now they all of them can
pretty much try something new and then
go on to it if it don't work you can
always go back to old faithful you can
always go back to what you are calling
on iop burgers fries and shake you can
always go back no we're not going back
to the burger fries and shakes all right
we are done with that life we we want
new things man we want a new restaurant
opened up in that place we're done with
the burgers fried chicken i want some
tacos why do i only have to have burgers
hustle
my point is they they can coalition they
can they can wrap up gigs after that
move on to something else what about you
bet what about you do you have pretty
much the same opinions
coalition can definitely make something
new just like three four three could
make something new if gears personally
gears we've
uh i mean how many gear scans we gonna
talk about here how many times you're
gonna talk about gears out of e3 it
would be great to spice things up have
something new a new original ip from
them
i don't care what the title is i don't
care what the damn setting is i want to
see these guys really push the envelope
and make something that can be a sleeper
hit that can lead to a new franchise and
that way you have options
yeah so
here's my thing
people say they want a comic book game
they always want a comic book game give
coalition the punisher
i i i really feel like attic not
speaking my life punisher
they would make a great punisher because
addicts stop talking that's enough
that's what you have to say that's not
enough that's all you have to say punish
your coalition with the damn gore they
be but let them i will say let them
finish gear six because i love where
they're going with the franchise i know
a lot of people don't and especially
story-wise and a lot of people prefer
the other other gears now i'm not saying
that the other gears is better or worse
i'm just saying that like i really enjoy
why i play against five and i would like
a conclusion to that story before they
spend three years making three or four
years making a punisher compulsion games
we don't know what they're doing and let
me tell you guys i've tried oh my god
have i tried no one said
that popular i'm gonna let that just uh
die
frank castle that don't do that all
right let's not let's not do this let's
not have this conversation
he might be the most thorough one about
the you know on that man i'm not gonna
say i'm not gonna say it i'm not gonna
say it
okay
and the word in the words of cipher from
uh the matrix ignorance is bliss
compulsion
i feel like people sleep on
i feel like this company
can do great things if they're given the
opportunity i don't know exactly the
kind of funding that's put over there i
know they got a new building so clearly
microsoft has a lot of faith and you
know what i want to point out to you
guys let me go ahead and look uh the
chat you guys got this all right i'm
taking i'm going back to facecams you
guys have this list if you want to see
it go to that list
i feel like
it says a lot
that the only game from their from their
older stuff that we don't know
is compulsion
we don't that's the only game why are
they holding compulsions game this long
like it to me that feels like they have
a lot of faith in that game that they're
saving that for something i don't know
what it is and trust me
all the people i normally talk to that
tell me all the little juicy gossip no
one knows what this game is
this game is so secret it's unreal
and that's why i have so much faith in
it because like i honestly feel like if
this studio is back the way it needs to
be back they can make the next bioshock
because they have like for those of you
that don't like we happy few i get it it
wasn't the greatest game made and i even
said don't buy it when i reviewed it but
if you go back and you play those dlcs
that came after that those are narrative
focus they're not survival focused
amazing narratives
and i feel like that's the potential
that they have
so let's let's move on you guys double
fine do we really need to talk about
them they're going to do what double fun
wants to do i don't think no one's
forcing double fine to do anything
they're going to make a platformer i
think you go both agree on that
there's going to be a platformer it's
going to be in game plus you can move on
the initiative
or if we dock right now i don't think um
you know even with
even with what we're hearing about
them getting help from crystal dynamics
and everything
um
i i don't want to speak too heavily on
it only because i'm not really sure how
this type of thing works i know that one
studio will get help from other studios
i know that the last of uh uh naughty
dog got help from santa monica and
development for the last of us too we
all know when but we know that that type
of thing happened we know that support
studios will come through and just do
and do just that that will come together
i don't even know why that wasn't even
blown out of proportion with this guy
but i didn't i didn't really i didn't
realize it either that's why i kind of
stayed silent on it i'm
i'm excited to see what they have to
offer in terms of that's one of my
favorite franchises perfect dog i don't
i don't got to own that game on 64.
that's because i got it on xbox 360. and
i didn't need to rebuy it but i'm
excited for that one um
we'll see what they do with that and
then
again do their own thing because that's
what i thought that they were going to
do once they got there i thought that
you know gal again the rest of his squad
was they was i thought they were going
to have like a last of us type game but
they started a perfect dog so let's see
let's see i actually
i love what cognito said on iop last
sunday i actually would love if they did
that i know that's probably not going to
happen that they just stick to a small
aggressive team
and they partner with other teams to
merge ideas and make that type of game
because like imagine
next time they park from software
it like because i feel like
that kind of studio doesn't exist and
that would be crazy if that ever
happened where it's like the initiative
doesn't make sequels they make original
ips with other studios and that's what
their bread and butter is they have like
the best talent management wise that you
can get and obviously there's better
talent out there but i'm saying with
some of the best talent and then they
get the gr they parked with other
studios to exchange ideals exchange how
mechanics should work exchange how
certain story elements should work and
then they build the game off those
merits and i think that's such a unique
ideal it just might work
like
but hold on real quick i know we i know
we like pressed on time you don't think
that that would
not give them an identity in the first
place like just imagine if i'm here with
attic one day then i'm here with a big
cloud the other day and then i'm there
with blaze one day then i'm back with
luca you understand what i'm saying but
and i'm with all of y'all but i'm not
hustling do you understand what i'm
saying like you don't have your own i
think that's your own idea you don't
have your own you don't have your own
circle i think i think that would hurt
in sql wise
but if they're not making sequels why
does it matter
you know at the end of the day as long
as that quality there as long as the
games are good
no one's gonna care who the hell helped
them
like they're gonna be like look like you
know they come together they i feel like
what i'm more about is evolving the
industry that's what i'm more about than
anything else and i feel like
that would be a good way
to
incorporate new ideals because right now
i do feel like that's an issue we're not
getting new ideas we're getting the same
type of games over and over again it's
like that bad neo song like a and i just
want newer ideas into the industry and i
feel like the way things are going now
we're never gonna get to that point but
something like that something like
cognito said and i don't think it's
gonna happen but i think that would be a
great way to to to really incorporate
stuff because studios don't work
together like that on that level but if
you start doing that more often you're
going to see
ideals butting heads with each other
people budding heads with each other and
then you know in the in the past four
people would lose because they were the
highest of that rank in that studio now
you got someone of ladder on the other
studio to fight for that idea
so i think you know it would be
interesting that would be interesting uh
so
exile entertainment i know none of you
care about that game at all i love it i
love that studio but i know you guys
don't care about that studio i think
they're going to they make less like
waistline three waistline three yeah
slowly say that uh my level one homies
was playing that um it looked fun a
little top-down it kind of reminded me
of um and i know it's not exactly the
same but um what's the game that just
came out
diablo too it kind of kind of put me
into my frame and oh no no x-men legends
x-men legends comparison there we go it
kind of reminded me of that um i
wouldn't
you know
i would say before i can make a judgment
on that i want to play that though i
want to play the previous titles first
because it might actually be like super
good and i'm not going to judge them i'm
not going to judge them you guys are
going to kind of like not agree with
this i don't know i think they should
make fallout
um i think bethesda
has too much on their plate i'm sure
they're going to want to keep building
off of the universe in star field if i
don't think starfield is going to be the
only game in that franchise clearly
they're going to do more they got elder
scrolls i don't think they need fallout
and i think if you know
if if exile is willing to take on that
that project give first off they're
they're part of the original makers that
made fallout uh second off i think they
definitely have the ability to make a
great fallout game
and you know even if they took they made
a wasteland game in the fallout universe
that would be cool and that's just my
opinion on the matter
yeah we're not saying mojang because we
know they're minecraft minecraft
and more mine minecraft minecraft mobile
minecraft edition minecraft ninja theory
after oh the studio that everybody caps
for
the studio that everybody wants to cap
for even though they didn't play
hellblade i didn't play hellblade no
i don't i know i don't but i don't know
about addicts i don't know if addicts
say anything about elephants no i don't
really i don't really don't care about
it okay okay okay i was not sure i know
you can't afford it and played the
original i do think the original i do
think hellblade
is a very important game in terms of
that playstation style game
and i think that you know a vow is
important
and fable is important but i think
hellblade's a little bit more important
because it's it's appealing to an
audience that they don't have
yeah i just hope they made it um because
a lot of people complained about puzzles
being a little too
difficult for them in the original plus
they said uh
they wanted a little bit more depth to
the combat they answered those questions
and it should be fine i trust the
quality if you played the original they
you they literally used staff
like i'm talking about developers to
betray villains they had them you could
tell they were dressed up wearing
regular clothes they had like this
little hats
it was weird but they did a lot of cool
that's how um i don't know her name i
don't know the main character's thing
but that's how she actually got her
position there like they just saw her
one day it was like hey can you do this
and that's how they
put around uh is it sonofa sinead i'm
i'm not familiar with hellblade like
that but that's how they found like the
bank
what's her name big cloud
um what what's the hell what's this um
what's what's her name the main
character no no blade
do you know her action one name
what is it
what is it we're catholic
i haven't played in a while okay but you
don't y'all know what i'm talking about
what i said yeah yeah yeah the actress
she's not that's about that i'm talking
about the actress yes oh i don't even
know i don't know the actress i never
thought
she was on staff and they found it like
i saw a video on it but she was on staff
and they found it and then when they
found it oh
does does anyone in the chat know the
actress's name by any chance no i don't
know the actress's name i know senua
[Laughter]
okay well
okay
[Music]
uh i think we got it her name is
someone says selena
molina i believe she has a youtube
channel apparently she has she i think
she does doesn't she work for for
hellblade well that's what i'm saying
yeah they found her like and yeah she
does and they they have found her i
think she was doing animation
melinda i i can't pronounce it stuff but
it's in the chat
i'm about to kill her name but yeah yeah
but then they ended up finding her on
staff and i was hey can you do that song
i was going to kill her long before i
came in the chat
yeah she just like fell into the project
and then just became the poster and then
now she's uh
now she's well received for it
all right yeah
obsidian
that's you at it that's me am i the only
one that plays rpgs in the world man
oh my god
they made
what game is that out of the world oh
shout out to um thick tick
i'm about to kill her name
megan she knows she is
yeah
she was she was she was a guest on the
in-laws podcast she actually follows me
on twitter i still don't know why she
does that but i noticed she was like the
creative she was like the lead narrative
writer for the outer world and from i
understand that the game is extremely
funny and um addict that i had dmg
remember like i think one of the first
times i dm'd you i said yo so you follow
me that's the orphan to just play the
game just based off the strength um otto
ross looks funny to me um somebody um
they made the comparison of captain
homer simpson or something like that i
love the simpsons i love futurama um we
know that they have a sequel coming out
to the outer worlds too that's why i'm
gonna play the first one and that that's
what she's working on too she's on the
other worlds too oh bet and then i think
they probably need to stay in their lane
if this game is like 12 hours long he
got a vowel
two games involved in the outer worlds
okay
the 18's working on a valve
which i i don't like using the word 18
but i do think like i think a team
incentive is like the majority of the
studio if that makes sense like uh but i
do know that their their
focus is about and most likely wants a
vows over
that studio that was working on a vow
because they probably got a good
sizeable amount of team working on the
outer worlds but once the vow is done
and wrapped up those people most likely
will go help with outer worlds too and
you know you know
i think we'll i think outerwear is too
going to be a good game man and i think
a vow is going to be a good game i think
obsidian is their is one of the best
duties that they own uh i actually i
would prefer that you know people saw
what work on elder scrolls work on
fallout no
let them work on the outer worlds
franchise and let them work on a vow
like let
obsidian has been building other
people's [ __ ] way too long let them
build their own
i agree
playground games
aren't they making another game aside
from uh they're making fable open world
yeah i'm saying it was fable well
uh
i guess when we see it
don't know what to really say about it
to be honest well that was turn 10 who
was making that
no playground games is making fable they
make fours on fable
no okay all right well we're gonna get
the fourth so you know no need for me to
sing for it so again because you know
it knows uh that's all he's had for uh
his diet for a while i can't stand forza
man every time i see him up there get
like a vein popping my forehead man like
no if someone want to assassinate me
they just wait for a ford to pop up they
know exactly where to cut like oh man
this is the new one the new one looks
good though it looks great i don't know
if y'all seen the the gameplay it looks
really really good uh the new the newest
horizon one i'm looking forward to yeah
it looks it looks good here's a big game
for you guys
rare
stick to uh what was it oh i want i
don't want to be respectful when i say
this see it see if thieves see a thieves
kind of it started off a little rocky
but apparently get turned back around
thank you they got disney
yeah yeah jack sparrow joint and hey
look
i say you stick to that and we talk
about you know things going in the game
pass all the time that's a staple of
game pass well the players like that
wasn't banjo quite a rare yeah
i feel like
apparently briar doesn't want to make a
banjo but i'm just like
like i don't know why
it's an option i'm not for the xbox i'm
not going to tell studio they can't work
on something that they don't want but
it's like i'm sure if you talk to
someone in rare and double fine there's
people in both of those studios that
ambition they want that one chance
give them banjo and let them come
together and make a banjo game like man
why can the initiative co-develop with
crystal dynamics why can't get a banjo
like what is going on here man
let's get some code developing going on
let's get that bachelor up and going man
i personally give you rat [ __ ] they
should give you banjo as an option to
get into that demographic i'm saying
look it would help
rareness
to me i have nothing no problem with
rare but i i don't like that game i'll
be real gonna be 100 with you that i i
know they're being successful what they
doing let's get let's get see these up
out of there let's get it let's get
everyone wild up out of there man like i
want rare to make me a banjo i don't
care what sacrifice has got to be made
but until that badge was coming out that
i'm on rare's neck i don't care who
makes it but until i get a banjo rare is
on my [ __ ] list okay like because it's
to me i see see these and i enjoy seeing
these to be honest with you i think it's
a solid game it's just not for me to
play like consistently or constantly
like that but all i see is kind of like
when i saw death loop i see see thieves
isn't banjo and i'm just like i don't
want to play this and you know what they
would do that pissed me off even more if
they give me banjo skins and a banjo
[ __ ] imma uninstall that bastard if that
ever happens
y'all got it man um i got a theory real
quick before we move on yeah um go ahead
everything's gonna take microsoft is
going to or xbox is going to have their
own universe um i heard this on podcast
unlock back when marty schliever was on
it and he was like yo everything is
going to revolve around every other game
so it's going to be not southern games
in it i believe i truly believe that
that once everything gets on the court
you'll see like a little easter egg like
in the order 1886 uh big cloud you
remember this when you picked up a sac
boy yep um yeah well you know what you
feel easter egg um
i think i think that they'll like
implement a lot of stuff like that i
don't want to see that though that's
going to piss me off that's going to be
hilarious i'm i'm cool because you
already had sac boy you you yeah i'm
saying you had plenty of attack boy
games before he was even in that game so
it's like
yeah you haven't had a rare you haven't
had that banjo so all right banjo so
we're we're going to speed past these
last couple turn 10 and undead labs
under the lads making state of decay
turn 10. i don't really care what the
hell you saw the trailer for the new one
though right the new one looked
what for they gave
i'm not with cgi stuff i got to see the
game i say you don't think it's going to
i i got friends and workers i got
friends that work at undead and you know
i got a lot of confidence in them but
until i see gameplay i got to go with
look i expect to stay at a uh three to
be good but until i see game play i
can't really be hyped for that uh turn
ten thank you let me throw this at you
though okay
just real quick just quick gloria i'll
catch you so you saw
so obviously what last of us two you
know and how well that was received do
you think they'll take inspiration from
that i don't want to collect i don't
want them to not necessarily the
narrative it's about just the quality in
terms of how they go i don't think they
can like i would like for them to do
something like that maybe with the next
gen hardware is like the series x they
can do something like that come out to
2023 yeah and that's when you're going
to get the cons is fully pushed
yeah i mean
we'll see we'll see as long as it
doesn't
affect the bottom line of what state of
the case is about you know what i'm
saying um and then you know it comes to
turn 10 that studio might not exist to
me like i i don't know the only the only
reason playground game is harsh the only
reason playground games is to me is
because of fable if it wasn't for fable
that you might as well just take those
two like
to be 100 with you microsoft owns 22 21
studios to me okay like they don't own
23 because
you're basically calling them catering
at that point
well see they have to cater like just
because i don't like racing games
they they're getting destroyed well not
destroyed but they're they they need
help in europe and and those racing
games is how you do it so like they they
need that demographic but i ain't that
demographic so i don't care they don't
exist to me
uh
bethesda guys bethesda this is the bread
and butter what i think a lot of these
stuff
we're not gonna talk about alpha dog
games because i don't think we're gonna
uh we'll talk about tango uh game works
we'll talk about that uh we'll talk
about machine games we're not gonna talk
about rouse house uh roundhouse studio i
don't wanna talk about studios that
really released and i know one of these
studios do mobile games i don't think no
one cares about that uh so but that's
the game students what are they doing
hustle what is what that's the game
studio doing
what are you i feel
star do you think they should continue
with the star field and elder scrolls do
you think they should try to develop
something new on top of all that or you
think they should just focus on those
two games
now focus on star field in particular um
because that that's supposed to be like
the the biggest one out the whole
acquisition the reason why you got it so
i think they they get to that they stick
to that um i think it's gonna
have to make a prediction but i think
it's gonna be the next fallout or i
think it's gonna be his biggest fallout
um earlier you would say something in
reference to you should get fallout to
somebody else and i agree i agree i
think you should give that to somebody
else my dogs are really fighting right
now let me be i'll be right back
they're going at it so so uh big cloud
man
but that's the game studios should they
make something new
uh
honestly stick with starfield i agree
i'm down with that stick stick with
starfield you're fine you got him you
gotta you already got the reputation
from there
uh
nah i think they're fine yeah i well
let's be real here by the time wars
by the time star feel comes out and by
the time elder scrolls comes out i might
be dead so it's like
like those games yeah you're doing that
you know how long
you know how long it's going to take to
make elder scrolls six
like
we might be at the middle of next
generation by then so like
they're fine they don't have to worry
about nothing man uh cinemax online do i
this is their online studio keep in mind
anything this studio makes most likely
is going on playstation i don't see the
studio uh being an exclusive i think
everything they make is going to be
multi-player uh what do you think that
zenimax online do you think that they
they're doing fine
with the elder scrolls online because i
feel like a lot of people love that game
like a lot of people love it yeah i
haven't heard any complaints before i
think they're fine they just
i don't know really what to say when i
think they're good with with the online
part
i agree i agree i agree i don't really
think hustle gonna really say too much
about uh xanamics i don't think he plays
too much tango games
is is is definitely something that i
feel like we could talk about for a
couple seconds because i feel like this
is one of the potential studios that
microsoft owns
that could actually
deliver some unique fruit uh the evil
within for those of you who don't know
that the evil within one and two was
good games they're making that ghost
wire that looks like trash uh i don't
think i'm wanting to play that i am like
why are we doing this
look i just don't like the way it looks
i just don't i don't like the way it
looks like
until i see some more different types of
gameplay i'm not saying i need to stop
using the word trash but like i use the
word trashy games i don't care about
everything's trash i don't care about
i'm sorry be real with you uh it doesn't
mean that the games are trash it just
means i don't particularly care for that
game i'm gonna try to be better on using
the word trash because i think that is a
little harsh um
i feel like this studio
needs to to go to do something new
because i feel like this studio is such
a talented studio because of the evil
within
make a horror game you know what get
kojima over there parked her up with
that studio and these two studios need
to come together and make some out of
the work this world stuff that i feel
like i have to be on acid to play game
because i feel like those two games
together
is making some crazy game that we might
have to like be banned in a couple
countries
like what do you guys feel about this
studio
well well skip me because i just got
here it's it's uh it's the people who
make the evil within
ghost wire studio
i i would i would say you know if they
even went with and does seem pretty
successful i would say make another one
of those even though i don't like horror
games historically if y'all know me i
know i really i know that's happening
you're afraid of her against come on man
you goddamn right now hey listen uh you
ain't going late you ain't gonna like
who my next guest is after thursday
though
oh you ain't gonna like who we got you
ain't you ain't gonna like what we got
next then uh look at you look at look at
your full shadow i probably will love
who you have next however
you love her
you'll love me because you ran away from
her in resident evil uh village
oh yeah oh he
uh you didn't get the talk man would you
like i don't know i did actually
i don't realize breaking news
yeah sure i just broke your hair on that
on ice
you got to talk to me
next week elsina demetres will be on the
podcast the face model of alcino the
very face model that's crazy you know
you over there doing your stuff man like
i personally like the the other ones is
more my taste i don't know why people
went crazy over that tall chick like hey
watch your mouth
no no i i'm not no
no no i'm not saying
i'm saying
that
there is some weird stuff going around
over that tall chick like stuff that you
don't see
like you see some creepy stuff in the
industry but for that particular woman
it was it's worse than bowser you know
what happened with bowsette uh hustle
when they were doing that [ __ ] yeah it's
it's worse than i would say it's worse
than that it was like bro um
she's a video game character and some of
y'all are really pushing this look but
mike fury all right those curves those
melons oh my god see look this is what
i'm saying this woman does weird things
to people like
man your chat's about
yeah literally she she um
she's won the best villains like it's
better than except
i might
you know even if i'm at work i'm gonna
have to pop into that and just look at
that chat because you're about to have
the weirdest chat next week be prepared
you're about to i thought my channel is
getting weird listen my chat was getting
kind of spooky when we have uh you know
the voice of bayla from the game mm-hmm
and she was awesome she was awesome talk
to her name's becca pruitt she was
amazing talk to but it was getting it
was getting there
but a lot of dudes are sitting there
going you're right you need to get uh
you need to get lady demon trust god i'm
sitting going home maggie there's
something going yeah magnum's going
okay
i reached out to maggie and she said no
so it was that but i was like okay i
know one person who wasn't wednesday no
and that was the actual model herself
because she
she's actually a fan of the show that
was shocking that bro did you find out
you shouldn't be shocked by that by the
way i was shocked by that notice she
because she watched the the interview
with uh uh becca and she loved uh how
much fun we were having so
that shot
that's how i go that's that's the game
you know
when you get that you congratulations
here's one of the first one i would say
here's one of those the pillars to
bethesda's studios id
it
it's software
like what do you guys think they should
make it i don't think they're making
another doom i feel like the exp uh the
expansions
finish that
kind of thing up but i feel like i feel
like they're going to make that other
game that other game that uh that but
that sounds no they're not they're not
making another rage they're not making
quake
uh maybe wolfenstein
i don't think they're gonna make
wolfenstein man
i think it's quake man like i don't know
part of me feels like they're showing
that remake because they about to drop
that quake
trailer in the next like year
like i think because i don't think
they're gonna make a doom i i think give
them something high-paced we need
something high-paced you know uh what's
that bubble gum [ __ ] game that
people kept talking about uh duke nukem
like
let them remake an actual proper duke
nukem like like give them something that
look at look at hustle
they're not they're not gonna do that
with with with the time frame that we
live in
i don't i don't even i don't even know
what type of game duke duke is i ain't
never played it
okay just think of uh the most uh
misogynistic uh
sister white male that you can possibly
think of they're not they're not they're
not doing that though they're not doing
it there's plenty of other things they
could do like yeah yeah but they're not
doing duke nukem i
i can guarantee you that one can you
imagine how that would go over like if
if they make duke nukem how they used to
make them back in the day because i
played that game on playstation that
that's not going over well i'm just
gonna keep it real with you that ain't
look listen they what's up they changed
laura kroft and yeah
you know that man but then they need to
make doom like let them make doom or
quake i feel like that's the studios
that really going to benefit the man
this video is going to benefit them okay
dishonored three i don't care what you
guys say i want dishonored three i i
don't want no death flute two that's
okay but until you get me a dishonored
three i don't want to hear nothing from
this damn studio oh yeah that's right
right right whatever that game's called
um
this is me foreign
[Laughter]
i'm not feeling that game i have to see
more on that oh no no no so you you were
the you were the champion this whole
chat now you turn into the villain
nominee you made the heel was supposed
to be me that's okay i'm okay with being
the villain why why no no that's my job
nah i'm okay with being no give me my
dishonored three no give me my
dishonored three or get out of my chat
give me my dishonored three man that's
all i want in this world it's my
dishonored three it's all i want i don't
think they need look can we get can we
get out of this thing where everyone has
to make like 18 different teams in the
studio i feel like studios need two
teams
what they working on now what they
working on later like i don't think like
a studio needs like eight teams because
i feel like
if once those teams start falling back
the other teams are gonna get thrown to
that team anyway so like that that's my
personal opinion i just feel like me
personally being the selfish individual
i am
i want
dishonored three and that's what i want
and i'm not going to stop shouting off
rooftops until i get my dishonored three
what what do you guys think
i wanted to take some time to correct
you machine games they're the ones who
make yeah
wolfenstein yeah they make waffles oh
that's that's the last game we're gonna
talk about uh yes that's next is
wolfenstein so when it comes to
arcane what are they making man do you
guys think they should uh you know make
a dishonored three which is the correct
answer may i add that that's the correct
answer or do you think they should maybe
you know try try a new ip or maybe do
death flute 2.
def loop too considering the reception
that everybody is kind of given this
game you know what you know the only
thing
today it's really going to be it's
literally going to be hellblade the
situation like hellblade 2
all over again with that game dude that
that would be a funny thing definitely
two only reason they're making it only
reason they're making it is to make sure
it's exclusive on their platform
yeah
all right explained earlier i still
gotta get back into it that's pretty
good machine gun games man machine gun
games
um
i think they should make something else
i don't think they should go back to
wolfenstein i think after i mean they're
making indiana jones but i i don't even
i i don't know why they're making that
game but i think they should be listen
i'm gonna be honest with you because
because i'm gonna say this on your show
addict i want you to look at the camera
i'm saying this
if this game look at the camera i'm
looking i'm looking at the camera no no
no you're not looking at the camera no
i'm looking at you
i always look at your camera so i can
look at you with my there you go that's
all i want look at your camera
i'm gonna be honest with you i'm okay
right here on that i'm gonna sit right
here on this platform if this game plays
like uncharted 4
we'll have some problems if this game
plays like no no no no exactly
four we will have some problems now
you're looking at a lot of people saying
that a lot of people complain about and
try to force especially with the rope
and all the mechanics and it's exactly
the same
you look at your camera you look at your
camera okay this game plays like
uncharted 4. that's a w
that's a dumb no no no no you don't
deserve that you don't deserve that w
that's mine that's ours
it's your own
creativity explain how you're gonna
explain to me how you go how are you
gonna claim a game play style explain to
that she did i just did cause i'm bitter
and jealous
i i tell you this um if there's one
thing that the xbox needs
they need an uncharted clone dog like
that's my favorite franchise period
until the two favorite game of all time
last night was part one second favorite
game but it's important the reason why i
say that
microsoft i don't think that they have
anything like an uncharted
so every now granted it's indiana jones
and nobody care about her that's unfold
oh that's i don't care
it better
i don't know anybody they might uh they
might get troy baker
oh i'm almost sure of it i'm almost sure
of it oh so just be myself and then yeah
look
however they do it if if they are making
indiana jones which i think atticus said
that cool i want that to play like
uncharted because they need that they
need something that's like heavily story
driven if they can hit if they hit the
gameplay right cool if they hit the
story right for me even better i'm i
just want like the uncharted two vibes
that's that's what that's what i per
in a perfect world
and that's what i want graphically all
that all that all that to like come
together so xbox gonna have their
offering of what in our charter would be
on their platforms look to be fair
expect out of this game like on some
road do y'all expect uh like it's gonna
be it on charter clone it's gonna be an
uncharted club
to me
it's only right
that
indiana jones gets to copy off
uncharted what uncharted copied
everything off of indiana jones like
that that until i'm ready yes that and
that and some things from tomb raider
yes but
yeah it says big cloud of witness
protection my bad i'm over here
adjusting my life
oh no hey guys right now there you go
you can see me in my room
that's just one of the things that in my
opinion microsoft needs that it needs to
be third person um since we are making
these uncharted comparisons if it's just
like that for me for hustle and
motivation just speaking for me i
wouldn't mind that whatsoever i just
want like to have like some type of
in-depth story tight controls fun
gameplay elements some cool little
puzzles hanging obviously i don't want
them so i love uncharted i don't want
them to copy everything off of uncharted
but but to me there's a reason that that
type of gameplay is done so well because
it is a good loop it's a good loop of
gameplay uh the biggest thing that i
i lean more towards tomb raider uh in
like the reboots than i'd lean towards
uncharters because i feel like they put
more
of a
human thing on laura croft than they did
nathan drake like i feel like like you
know by the end of that game
i was seeing more character development
and like
feeling like she's trying to survive the
nathan drake nathan drake felt like he
was like like forget about super
soldiers send nathan drake's across the
seas like
because he that dude doesn't miss he
doesn't care if he kills a thousand
people
like you felt when you see two like
laura croft kill people in the reboot
you felt that she was enjoying what she
was doing she was surviving though
so you know she was very fragile in the
first one she wasn't really a killer she
would just explore and she becomes uh a
badass in the first one then
now again she's uh tomb raider yeah so
you know that's pretty much all about it
and the last thing i want to talk about
real quick all these studios who do you
think is the most important studio of
their game
initiative and this is
that's that's the new studio that's the
one that you that's the talent that
you're calling
that's the naughty dog up there
which studio is the counter to what
playstation studio
oh okay
um well initiative is you know the
the coalition would be the counter to
the initiative in my humble opinion i
did a video on that once upon a time in
terms of consistency um they proven that
with guests four gives five guest
tactics and gears um
have busters so they've proven that to
me
um
big clap
oh no no because i want to just do one
and then i'll pass it off because i
don't want to just keep going yeah yeah
okay
because i personally feel like naughty
dog's still their best studio and sony
is the most consistent studio so what do
you think huh
that's what i'm saying is like
which one will fall
yeah
who did you say insomniac was hustle
zombie was the coalition okay coalition
who do you think your insomniac is
um
you know personally looking at the list
maybe obsidian that's i'm obsidian so
i'm saying i'm sitting put in the chat
put yours in there too man put put your
you know put put your versions of who
soniak is right now um so i think would
definitely be the initiative i think i
agree with special there yeah i think
obsidian
is going to be there i'm going to throw
out good quality games over and over
again and i'm gonna do
little to no wrong just like insomniac
all right so
let's keep naughty dog for last because
i do think naughty dog's still their
best studio
um sucker punch
who is their version oh sucker punch
from this list um well i think that's
all they're getting their studios
yeah i got you i got you got this that
was tough that was tough that was tough
i would say for me i'd say it's software
and i'm not a fan of like the doom games
and stuff like that but if i had to make
it like some type of
yeah if i had to like put them up in a
fight like i think i would be more
comfortable with doom with the people
who made them winning that fight and
it's awfully i'm with that
huh
i'm going to say this at least have been
fighting chairs i'm saying the
initiative
so okay all right wait so you see you
know so we said we said the initiative
is the naughty dog no you guys said the
that's what we're initiative
that's the same
we said
you're saying that that's the sucker
punch
of then what's the naughty dog
that's a good question that we're gonna
get to that we already answered it we
already answered it
i think
but there's the game studios is their
naughty dog
i think that's the one that's going to
give the most quality out of all these
studios
i think
i think elder scrolls is a 90 plus
already like and it's not even out i
think starfield nine times out of 10 is
a 90 plus game like out of all these
studios here none of them have delivered
more than but there's the game software
none of them have
a and you know it to a point
even naughty dog hasn't performed what
what they've done like they've performed
extremely anticipated game but usually
when bethesda launches an rpg it
changes the whole genre almost every
time
we haven't seen them do much of anything
for a while like you know obviously even
even their their game on the worst day
fallout 4 is like an 87 88 on metacritic
then i said three four three i'm shocked
they said 343 would be their uh naughty
duck
oh oh no i might say sorry [ __ ] no
no
you got me on that one all right all
right here's a good one saint monica
um according to what i'm seeing here
i would have said i would have said
bethesda
for for santa monica i would have said
personally
okay what do you see
um
coalition maybe
oh
i'm saying ninja theory
i'm saying ninja theory i i don't wanna
listen i gotta see how hell i gotta see
just the results of hellblade too
firstly before i say that that's that's
they did great with the first one on the
budget this is this is it on a full
fledge you know
backing but
nah i'll say bullish
oh you guys don't like that dude you
didn't like that one did you
all right so you know that that's pretty
much it we you know i said uh but that's
the game software for naughty dog and
you guys said um
um
get that initiative
they got to live up to that they
like listen it's either naughty dog or
bust and i'm not going to hold you up
like they they got to live up to that
though like that's that was the first
one that they announced when they when
they 2008 i remember e3 2018. oh we
jumping out the gate oh xbox don't got
no games all right well we got a whole
new studio for you like they got they
gotta live up to that they gotta they
gotta be top [ __ ] they got you though
i'm looking forward to the last time we
saw that game uh we got we
funny thing is the last update we got
for that game from um
you know from ninja theory hellblade
they were taking pictures of the foliage
they were in level design of the map
remember they would take a picture of
the island or wherever they were at so
it's like
we don't know how far we are from from
this when you're you know level design
that means you haven't even built the
the main foundation you haven't done
okay
look i i see people clowning us for not
saying playground games
if i were to say playground games i
would say they're another form of
insomniac because they do make a lot of
high quality games but until i see that
fable
i can't really give them that insomniac
level they make great floors or horizons
but if they make a good fable
i would i if they make a great fable i
would put them up there
with uh with him sonia easy but until
they make another another ip because
that i feel like the moment they showed
how quality of a spider-man insomniac
made they were able to get that kind of
publicity but until we see
the consistency in the different types
of genres that they make we can't give
them that type i'm not saying that fable
isn't going to be good but i'm saying we
need to see fable and i think fable has
a great chance of being great but we got
to see it and we haven't even seen
gameplay from it yet
i agree with john rocks we said um turn
10 is for basically their polyphony and
double fine is media molecule i agree
with that completely i think double fine
i think double fine is is on another
level of the media monocle i think
saying that that media molecules is that
is double fine as their media molecule
is disrespectful to double fire be real
was their media molecule actually um if
i had to like do something in terms of
with uh minecraft with minecraft yeah i
put i'll put minecraft to be honest with
you minecraft's on another level than
anything on this on this list on sony's
list on anything and i don't like
minecraft
yeah it's it's one of the biggest ips in
the in in in gaming so like that's why
we know why that's the wildfire i don't
know why it is it because of dream dream
on twitter he he put that game on his
back and he went on a completely
different level man
that's another game two dreams dreams
still getting a lot of trash and dudes
making tv shows on and so
the only place i want to see dreams is
in my nightmares i don't want to see
that game
i don't know yeah i definitely you know
we're going to end this here man you
know this one a little bit on because uh
you know but big cloud wanted it and he
gives a lot of good insight for we're
gonna i'm gonna get these a little bit
of super chats real quick that uh i did
uh first off i want to appreciate
everyone coming through for uh liking
the channel for coming and listening to
us uh you know say some crazy stuff
about these studios clearly everything
we say is our opinions i know for some
reason people want to act like
everything i say is facts uh it's not
it's my opinion and i have every right
to
hop on my opinion and never let go
uh so let's there's a couple super chats
real quick
uh okay so i'm pretty sure the last one
i see okay so i find all the super chat
from raiden blade in the words of z and
j dub in the behemoth you are so stop
crying and convert
you ask for it now you gotta suck it up
oh my god
um right yo shout out to z man uh zaire
you know i i've never seen eye to eye
with a lot of things zaire does
but one thing i can honestly say about
that man is he stays true to himself and
he never switches up
all these years he's made the same type
of content and he's always improved his
content and you you got to got to give
him that shout out man got to give him
that shout out so you got to fight out
super chat from raid and play no
nintendo are the smartest they get you
while you're young and why everyone buy
nintendo without gotta agree with you
there they they do kind of get they got
to get you when you're young that sounds
so bad we're good we're going to move
past that i mean everybody could say
nintendo was their childhood growing up
everybody yes we we got a two dollars
from flame compulsion is it me and this
is the key
the people were making the pc ports oh
no oh my god say they sold no um
we got a two super chat from raiden
blade maria you gain something like that
butchering that whole damn name we're
moving past that and then jiggy g with
the two dollar super chat this is a
great show even though big cloud is a
hater you a hater big cloud
that's [ __ ] j chica j i don't i don't
know about big club being no hater
however big club i do have a question
for you kind sir what's up
what's the name of your podcast and when
does it come on and where can we find
you
oh
thank you
well my my podcast name is the rgt
podcast we do it every friday this
friday we got uh xbox pope coming
through so we're going uh okay
talk to pope art about a few things um
this thursday we have agent 47 coming
through it's gonna be me and him
one-on-one interview get to see how
basically talked about him you know his
impact on our childhoods you know the
you know the industry um how he's been
and obviously get a you know get some
good questions in for him especially on
why he didn't play the damn character in
the movies because i saw these they have
hit bad movies they weren't uh they hit
different when you don't have you know
hitman in there so that's what's going
on there and of course i already dropped
the jewel here on the show uh next week
i'm already working on the time with her
right now let's go away for a reply but
uh sherry said she's coming through so
next week um we are going to have lady
demetresk on the show
and i'm looking forward to talk to her
as well but yeah okay that's me big
cloud gaming youtube twitch twitter i'd
appreciate the uh invites yeah i put his
twitter's in the in the chat definitely
go to that you know follow him on
twitter uh you know big cloud's getting
some uh unique perspectives in the
industry that i don't really see a lot
of people get man like what i like about
you is like you're getting a lot of the
voice actors too and stuff like you know
like yeah yeah and i don't see people
doing that ever
and i i like yeah i like that like you
given i'm gonna let you know uh if i get
a particular one that i looked out for
um because
i talked to a certain person about and
uh
i'm gonna give you a hint this this
individual play store
oh play store
play store in
god of war ragnarok
oh
no
i'm waiting i'm waiting to see if we can
get uh that individual one i've been
waiting to fill a cup just like two days
now but um
hopefully we can work something out
there but yeah like that's the thing i
really like just i don't know i just i
feel like i shine better just talking
you know i mean naturally to everybody
and um
having the ability to talk to the very
you know people bring the
characters to life is awesome
yeah i get that man and hustle what if
people
can find you at man uh you he is in the
description by the way you guys can
definitely go in there uh but what do
you got going on man well
you gonna be streaming this week annie
hopefully if i don't have to go to work
then i will be streaming more than
likely this weekend hopefully hopefully
i'll keep fingers crossed if i don't
have to work i'm streaming wwf no mercy
on the nintendo 64. my retro tank should
be here friday or friday night according
to what i saw in the post office
uh your retro tank is just like a
pass through before you hook it up to
the uni you need to keep me updated on
when you go live because uh what i'm
gonna start doing is uh um hosting you
on the iop twitch channel i i wish they
would do so i wish they would do that
something like that on on youtube
youtube needs more you can raise yeah
more type right here
that'll be yeah it would be nice um at
big club
you you got some real good stuff brewing
over there and i just saying that
because you're here you've invited me to
your platform countless times i'm going
to get you back on i'm i'll know
vatican's free next week because i have
uh cognito coming through next week so
if y'all want to come through as well i
mean we can have iop
rgt showcase or something it's all about
well that's that's what it is no no you
you keep working i see you i see you i
see blaze over there i see um mr
troubleshoot gaming over there every so
often but it's good to see you vic oh
yeah it's good to see all y'all like
growing like that and the niche that you
have now i mean i'm a little upset you
beat me to it but the niche that you got
is like you have you're interviewing a
lot of different people that we don't
see like yeah people see executives and
ryan mccaffrey and shout out to jay
barry and persona they're going to have
sean layton on on their podcast
that was awesome but i was like you know
that makes sense it works for him like
dude go for it have fun that's going to
be a great uh great show for them but me
yes i just wanted to be more you know
like we i don't want to be like the guys
so we see the same thing over and over
you know i mean i don't want to be that
yeah like like let's talk about gaming
how many podcasters did there talks
about
gaming you know i mean like you want to
you want to stick out in some particular
way and that's where that's what it came
down to rgt used to get into a lot of
wild stuff i was like nah i want to take
this to
a different direction it's been slow but
it's been
it's been worth it to watch it grow and
get more organic you know organic
reactions than what i did before
indeed and once again just thank you for
like opening up the platform to somebody
like me same thing with you addict yeah
i was just doing the comment section
y'all so this oh yeah i appreciate you
always being in the chat i'd be like bro
why isn't hustle not getting you give
you my dog yeah anybody but hit up
hustle i'll be chillin i'm glad you're
here though i'm glad you you know i'm
saying there's like
my grandmother told me when you play
good in the world sometimes it will come
back too you know i mean you put a lot
of good into everybody you literally you
know help spread the word for everybody
else so the fact that you're here
more people more eyes are on you on you
and you can grow your platform to where
you want to get it you know what i'm
saying just take that let's go with it
man just
be consistent that's all yeah
that's what's killing me it's it's
really just that it's nothing else it's
just the consistency and yes um me and
your grandmother we we agree on that
whatever you put into the universe is
what you uh whatever you put out to the
universe is what you get back there's a
reason why i'm welcome in so many other
circles and i'm not as popular as say a
lot of other people like there's a
there's a reason for that by the way
mm-hmm yeah i'm not the best gamer as
you all know so but now but but there's
a reason for that though a lot of places
a lot of ways that you can proceed and
content on youtube it's like i said it's
like the lighter effect so if you know
there is the quick ladder
but there's no ladder after that quick
ladder you know you got you got a real
short ceiling or there's the ladders
where sure there's more ladders to climb
there's a longer you know grind to climb
those ladders but there's lighters after
ladders and not just one big ladder that
gets you to the equivalent of maybe
three ladders on the other side yeah but
there's lighters after those three
ladders you could climb but the big
lighter only has one
so you know
it takes longer i do want to um do want
to tell everybody in the chat too
because i know this is like a xbox you
know crowd but i will be covering xbox i
changed everything back to what we were
aside from playstation i won't be
talking about xbox well but don't worry
thank you know
what you guys think no it's going to be
me my honest opinions on everything i
will give you guys my honest takes you
guys want to hear that it's big cloud
gaming youtube you'll get the same
respect you see me give to playstation
that's how i do it that's how i try to
do it and the only way i know how to so
if you want to hear my takes
you'll definitely see it but um
appreciate y'all and uh thanks for
having me again oh no no problem man you
know we're gonna go ahead and uh close
out of this uh definitely go follow
these people i put um
i put that clouds
uh twitter in the in the chat uh you
know and you can you can always follow
all hustle stuff in the uh the
description appreciate everyone coming
through man we we definitely you know we
we had up to like almost 240 people in
here 230. uh you guys come up here every
week definitely show how many ladders
again all right man i'm not going to
bring a lighter analogy again because
clearly you guys like to clown so you
know definitely iop this
iop this sunday uh one uh 11 am and i
love saying 1pm and i can't say it right
now 11am eastern definitely tune in for
uh you know the the iron lures podcast
we're going to be talking about stuff
hopefully some news happens between now
and then because
it's very dry yeah
you know it's so dry i might have to buy
kina that's sad that's how sad this
stuff is right now
you won you know what you was gonna buy
to begin with stop disgusting so so you
know
i might or might not buy that game and
give you guys some uh input on
these trees these trees uh well we
talked about it man i appreciate that
you don't like that playstation so you
like that xbox then i see yeah okay okay
but you know appreciate we're coming
through man it's going to be uh we'll
see you next week and uh see you on the
attic show